You
Hello, oh
It's me. Oh boomie left. So mommy just removed that
He was sitting next to me like up till one minute ago
Hi
I thought he was gone he was never he was never there in the first place
Hello, sir. I've been really busy today. I've been cleaning and taking care of a baby Fia. So
Busy
He's been a good boy today
I
Just staring at my slippers. I went to go find my slippers too, and I found one
On one side of the bed and I was like, where's the other one and I look under the bed
And I'm pretty sure a boomy had taken it under the bed and it was like I had to like crawl under the bed to get my other
Slipper is there any cake left? Yeah, there's no cake left
So cake left. Oh my god
I don't know if you heard that thump noise I bent down the pet boomy and he got scared
He's been really skittish
Do I need to like get you on anxiety medication, dude? Are you okay?
He's a skittish little boy
Yeah, Fia Fia is doing okay, she hasn't I had to um
Pure ray her food and
Kind of force feed her because she's very weak right now. It's hard for her to um
To eat. Oh boomy. Are you gonna lay in the bed in the kitchen?
Why do you face that way
Why are you leaning so much under the bed?
Let's see if let's give the people what they want
Why everybody truly came here it was for boomy
And the new cat cam
Um, but yeah, so she's uh if she doesn't improve with her eating habits
I'm gonna bring her to emergency again tomorrow and see if I can
See what else is going on?
Yeah, hi foo hi foo
This is boomy. He is my son. He is a one year four months
13 days old
I only know that because when I brought Fia to the vet, that's what they like said
Except minus like a month because she's a month younger. Um
He is a links point Siamese cat and he is
Wanted in multiple companies companies. Yeah, he's wanted from multiple companies for his crimes
Murderous murderous boy
He's not a chonker. It's just the angle. Okay, he's not he's a big cat in terms of like being large
But like he's not he's not he's not he's pretty he's pretty uh
He's a built
He's yeah
false allegations
Um boomy is a wanted wanted man
He doesn't seem to care that much as you can tell I also have my whopper in the back
Boomy likes the whopper and I have another bunny. You can't see the bunny though. He's peeking over the whopper and I have my
A gamer whoops, you like that boomy
He likes it. He loves it. He's co-sheebie. Um, so
So
I was gonna like role play as bb today
um
In which that I would go like full lore
accent
everything
Um, but I see that there's a few new people
Welcome new folks. Hi, my name is she be caught in bum. I am your favorite girl failure
Dumb of uh gen one velar
Indulge and I love to do role playing and play around my model and make streams interesting and do fun voices
um
And uh, yeah, so thank you for stopping by
What's wrong with your face, dude?
He's using cleaning mode
Uh
She be is our favorite dork. Um, so like last time I did an other ring stream. I literally farmed for
uh
four hours, but I was in character as like
Uh, she bees meese for the entire four hours just to make it fun and interesting
uh
I don't know if you guys would want me to because I would literally be british the entire time. I don't know. Do you want?
British
Bebe like, I don't know if you want me to like just improv me playing allen ring as a nun or not
Can you
No, I'm not gonna bring up shebethany. Shebethany's had her time in the spotlight for a bit. Um
But I wanted to kind of like give you that option because I did I also like my last few streams
Um, I haven't been able to stream because I've been taking care of my kitty cat fia
And if you don't know hi if you're new here, uh, my kitty cat fia has a unique uh disease where she occasionally
Uh, she usually recovers
Um, this depends on the speed
She gets paralyzed for the neck down because her body can't send the right chemical signals to make her body move
So I've just been taking care of her and she is my sweet little special needs kitty and I love her pieces
She is named after uh fia the deathbed companion ironic
I know
When I named her that I didn't know if she was like this
Um, but I do snuggle with her all the time. Um
She's my little snuggle companion, uh, yeah, and um
So yeah, I just wanted to give people some background
But yeah, what I was saying I haven't been streaming a lot because of that and I just did like a collab and
Membership streams, so I wanted to make sure that I was like people
Although I'm dressed as a nun right now people still know who I am
I know you're used to seeing you're used to seeing this
You're used to seeing this lady
Hold on let me bring her up
Uh ignore
Oh, wait, nope. She this is shebeth never mind go away shebeth and he we didn't ask for you
you're used to seeing um
a different sort of
Model and so like I mentioned I like to play around with my models and um
You you just a big lean in boomy
Oh, you need to squitches. Oh depends on you. Um
so
I
Uh, yes, I am tan
Hello, I'm tan
Again, I like to play with my models because it's fun. Like I have a vtuber model and I'm not gonna play around with it
You know, it's fun to dress up for streams
Even if it doesn't make sense like me being a nun right now
But I am going to be extremely say so I am a say so vtuber. I am a bun nun
It's fun that they mean rhyme. There's another one. Oh, I'm not done
May the lord pull up on you with a gun
I'm tired. Um, I'm not a rapper but I'm not a rapper
We going for a run
I always enjoy streaming for you a ton
Maybe I should start calling you hun boomy your tongue is sticking out
What's wrong with you bars bars praise be
Um
May the lord keep his peace as I keep mine by my side. Uh, so
Like I could totally like just role play the entire time
As that but I'm gonna save that
I might I might break into like bb bb might just take over
Uh, she got the holy flow. I got the holy flow though. I will ever let it go
Let the lord's light shunned on me. He'll always be setting me free. I put my faith in him
Tomorrow we will win against the demons and the monsters
You know, we're gonna rock her
We do and mow off the bat, um, what can we see them off it again? Uh depends
I got a bag for the Muppet
Rap game been real silence and she be dropped for mistake. I just stopped going to the gym. I keep missing start
No, no, no, I literally just started. I've just been talking. I haven't played yet
And what's the power level of a nun muppet? Oh, I don't want to even go there. It would be over for everyone
It would truly be over for everyone
I
Don't think so. We are
A nun pit a nuppet a nun pit
It's over 9,000
Bosses about to catch up as far as um, so what I was planning we do again. I haven't like specced anything
um
Why did I blink like so slowly? What the heck?
I'm like, hello
So, uh
We I still have four million runes
I didn't like spec after or anything because I wanted
To kind of consult with you guys on what I should spec into
Uh, some of you know, I've been
Just absorbing Elden Ring lore
Whether it be the dlc or otherwise and I already knew a lot about Elden Ring lore
But I just like wanted to update my stuff. Um
So I've done that
and uh
I'm very excited to get to the dlc
So I was thinking I need to get the thing that binds mogue
I'm assuming and I think somebody mentioned I should go to morgot
Michael West
And then I should also go to
Uh
What the heck is his name everything starts with g. Yeah, I need the shackle. Um
If you summon here, I'm in the dlc should they refer to me? No, you can use dlc weapons again
I will probably I only will really
Like I'll attempt bosses by myself first before I call you guys in like I've already seen so much gameplay of all the bosses
I've been watching um that one twitch streamer uh bushy for like like all of their runs
And I I'm pretty sure I've memorized mogue's moveset by now
I hope so I watched so many gameplay videos. I better have gotten better just by absorbing things
Um
Godfrey yes, uh that she had godfrey's ghosty ghosty boo
for uh the talisman pouch
um
Yes
But yeah, I know like so it's been widely known that this dlc is like the hardest
dlc or content game content that from software has put out so I probably will need your help
Oh my god guys, I got ice cream and it was a bad idea to eat it
I was like having a couple bites before stream and now my tummy does not feel good
My tummy is not doing too hot
Well, let's play a password. Yeah, I believe it's like she be I'm pretty sure it's just she be um
Yeah, I'm fine. Don't worry about it
For my stomach against so I'm thinking yeah, I haven't had ice cream in months. I wanted ice cream
Don't don't don't yell at me. Don't yell at me
Don't yell at me
Yeah, I bet I've seen gameplay of concert redawn. Um
I'm the type of person who I like to learn about everything before I start something
But it's still like I still don't even know how to get to the dlc
I've only seen gameplay of like the boss fights. That is the and only like the remembrance bosses as well
um
Yeah, a lot of like the normal I like because I know like the dancing lion is like the first boss technically that you run into
but yeah
Why didn't you take lactate because I like to I like to put torture myself
boomy
I want to spin you so people can see your doofy face
um
There's no trick getting to that you'll figure it out. Yeah, I'm assuming so
So
Patches concert to me is actually a canonical final boss. Um, but like I don't know
How to move around. I don't know the names of the cities. I don't know anything about the weapons
um, I'm only looked at like the lore for like like, um
mikala and redawn and
Miedra, whatever the heck his name is. Is his name Miedra? The one with the frenzy flame dude. I can't remember his name ever
um
I'm pretty sure I'm getting confused with the Zelda character. It's whatever
uh
and uh mesmer
Uh
boomy
You're breathing so loud. Are you snoring?
Excuse me
Excuse me, sir. You're being really noisy. You're breathing too loud. It's triggering me
Okay
He stopped
Um
I'm very excited for the bosses
She be hands
Or um
Do you want to play be guided to experience as much as lore is possible because npc class has so many dumb stuff
Uh, we'll see. I look I kind of like I like the I used to hate
But I kind of came to love it is the non-linear stuff. I don't need to look at the lore stuff
I already know everything about the lore stuff to be honest with you. Um
But yeah, the nails me popping is popping is popping
It's popping my nails match Reina's eyes
Boomi's eyes are a little bit icier. I see your blue
The one time boomi's not menace. She accuses of breathing. I'm starting to believe boomi
Oh, sorry, did I tickle your head? Probably deserved it
Yeah, he's been pretty okay today. I was I was surprised. I'm like, wow, you're so well-behaved, sir
Um
What
What do you mean was messed up like do you mean like like millennia and stuff because like I know about that like her stuff
No millennia america
Everybody has georgia or martin needs to stop naming people
Boomi's never a menace. He's always been accused of false charge just because he's good right now
He steals food from this disabled. I don't know what to tell you. He stole his sister's food
And you guys just excuse him for that I don't understand
um
He did probably I know I know for a fact he missed me the most
um, he like he
uh
He never comes and sits on my lap
and
Because he's a very much like I want to be in the same room as you cat and I'll let you pet me sometimes
But he uh, and he'll be like picked up and stuff, but he won't like
Sit on top of you or snuggle on your chest or anything. Um
and
he
And he came and he sat on my lap and like snuggled there for a very long time and I was like
aw
Okay, I can tell you really miss me and when I came home he started screaming
And boomi's like you've heard boomi like yeah, but he'll be like like all that stuff, but he was like full on like
And then fio was just like stuck to me like a like velcro
I would wake up and she was just like on my chest and I was like, I can't breathe
And then reina too reina likes to lay on my shoulder if he likes to be on my chest and boomi likes to lay on my feet
Um
I try my best I try my best to be a good mom
So, uh, what should we do first?
So one obviously we have to spec stuff. I don't even know. I don't know anything about the dlc weapons
I didn't look up anything. I literally only know the word
And so we got to get the shackle. We're gonna get the talisman pouch
And then we got to kill mog
And I think that's it. And then I think we can just launch into the dlc
What build am I thinking? I don't even remember what build I was going for
I think I was doing this. I've never done like been a sorcerer. So I'm pretty sure I I
Uh, I'm doing a sorcerer build
No, I'm not doing strength intelligence
Although that's just a good baseline to have going in
I think I'm level like 60 now or 65 and then I got enough levels for 130
me thinks
Yeah
Put everything to luck
It was a dex intelligence
I was actually
I feel like I was pretty across the board with my dex intelligence and my um
Whatchamacallit
Strength because I know I needed more strength to wield moon veil. Okay, let's make my headphones on
Max don't eating. Yeah
Yeah
Imagine the game didn't save the runes, uh, then I won't play
I will literally end the stream and I will walk away
Okay
Hooper
He's a little guy. Um
Let me turn my game volume down
Is the game volume okay for you by the way, I will leave with no hesitation
and then
I will just offline just grind four million runes again
I just clicked new game
Hold on let me get out of the way shall I?
So you can see that's how many runes I have actually maybe I should just come over here
You guys don't really need to see my
I'll put myself in the middle and see you guys constantly see I'm just like running through
Wait, what does that look like? I want to see now
Oh
That looks so disorienting
If I had a 3d model this would be fun because then I would I would literally just like turn it
I would just flip my 3d model and just make it
I would just make it um
I'm behind like I'm running through stuff
It's like I'm sitting behind a tall person at the cinema that's funny
All right, uh, I don't think anybody cares about my runes then
Nobody cares about the side of the screen
What does get up I should use a faith build? No, I've been literally I was a faith
dex build
When I played my own like I might by myself on my playstation
um
Because I did I use the halo scythe and a lot of um
Faith and incantations so let me just sit down actually
I
Wish the nuns and kindergarten was pretty
Uh
Oh, okay, I'm level 54. Okay. I thought I was much higher. Um, so I have 4,260,909
Uh, what should I put stuff into?
Do
What should be the minimum level of vigor that I should have going into the dlc
54 that's it. Well, yeah, I've been speed running
Okay
I'll do 60 bigger than
No, I need 60 we all know here that I would need 60
And so remember I'm doing intelligence as well. So I have intelligence
Okay, actually I'm technically doing like an intelligence dex build. Um
I'm so sorry to scare you with my gamer subs boomy. Here you go, boomy. This is a great product placement
Yep, and I know I yeah, I know about the scatter tree blessings. I know they do like shadow levels or whatever they're called
I'm not super again. I haven't played the dlc. I've only seen lore of the dlc
Um
This is not which you can't just do a game or something. Uh
And have your armor I
Don't know vigor means nothing compared to the scatter tree fragments. Yes, because from what I know they reduce
Damage
Taken and they increase damage given
I'm even tempted
to like speed run and get as many scatter but the thing is
the scatter tree blessings are also
Pretty dangerous to get to like I could probably get one shotted by trying to run someplace
Okay 70
That's true. I would probably would need
Because a lot of them need 70 anyways
But that doesn't leave a lot
Frank I'm actually might just do 60 for that
Yo
Yeah, that's why I can't so uh, I'm doing an intelligence build. I have no
Idea what that means in terms
But I was I'm doing an intelligence build because one I haven't done that before and two I heard those really fun sorceries in
The dlc that I want to try
I do not have I'm assuming you mean Ronnie's hat. I don't have Ronnie's hat. That's a good point
I would have what I would have to really
progress and Ronnie's quest line and I haven't done that. I don't think
I have a moon veil katana
It requires sacrifice if skibbity fragment
No, renala for the entire oh, I must okay. I'm assuming that renala
Is in the dlc
No
Yes, I can't remember their freaking names
I
renala
Ronnie's for ice magic. Okay, renala is
Related to the horse lady, right?
Or is she the horse lady?
It's like ronola
No, I already have the moon veil katana guys
Renala's sister. Yeah, ronola, renala. Who the fuck is there? I'm gonna. I mean, I said fuck
By the way
Are you cheating the stream? Yeah, I'll tweet the stream when I actually get into stuff
My friend did a sorcery and they worked pretty well until redon humbled him. Well, I'll probably be using
I actually haven't seen a lot of the consort redon fight
Besides like don't get close. So I'm probably gonna use a lot of distance magic like I have knight comet
Dex makes me cast faster
So, you know what I'll do? I'll probably do like
55 just so I have more stuff
Intelligence I can get talismans
I know I need more of this
It's like generally hard spreading things a month, but like I can respect like I did kill I didn't kill her. I did be um
You know
So
Yeah
I know yeah, he like really jumps over to you. I've seen like a couple gameplay, but I haven't like watched it a bunch
I could always get a talisman for endurance
I
Sorry, I'm just seeing how much I
Like I'm literally wondering if I should do something like that
This is hard for me because I do like odd numbers, but I also like divisibles of five. So I'm like
But I can't I can't make it a divisible of five
Yeah
Yeah, I like that's why I'm not I'm not too worried about armor sets
I am worried about like stamina for casting
I'm sorry, Reina is scratching in her scratching post. That's what that pinging is in the background. She's like slamming it. Um
I'm wondering if I should go with 50 bigger instead
I'm gonna do like that much
I
Think this will be fine. I think I feel good about that. What do you guys think?
Reina is strong. You have no idea
I
Big laser strap. Yeah, I can always like I like I'll probably going forward focus on
vigor just like leveling vigor
um
You think I should drop in by five and add it to decks
That's true. I don't have a lot of sorceries
You're thinking more dead. Okay. You're also thinking more decks
I know yeah, I know knight calm. I don't I'm not gonna run knight calm at a lot. It'll be there, you know
Uh decks for casting speed
Yeah, I know so like her that usually if you're above like 150
The bosses are harder. So that's why I'm at 130
I don't want to like I don't have a zers comment. I'm probably not again, you can't really use a zers
I could use a zers comment
on
Mogue because you just stand still but otherwise
Otherwise I probably wouldn't need to do that
You
What who said that I don't ever watch videos people said that
Am I dilulu
Hello, I don't have carrion slicer
I do love carrion slicer. I think they're wrong. They don't scale level. Okay
That's so weird. Why did people freaking say that then?
Big moon
Yeah, I can't do I already I already locked myself out of big moon though
Because I I use the runes too from um renala's remembrance
Oh
That's what it is unless it's new game plus and this is my first. Okay. That you're right
Thank you for pointing that out. You are so correct about that
Because that is what they said. That's what they meant. You're so right. I totally misunderstood
Yeah, I I know I can do better mausoleum. That's true. I didn't I didn't use mausoleums at all during my first ever run
Actually, I did but I never did anything about them like I would go to them, but I didn't do anything
The big bell turtles
Okay, you're right. You're right. I totally forgot about that too
I
Has been doing she's doing okay
Hmm
So you said you want me to lower what?
To ink put it into decks. I forget. Well, let me scroll up
Hey shebers. I like the new outfit. How's it going? I started outering and I've been playing it
So the past week and we're falling down the good fall down the rabbit hole lower into decks. Okay, so let's do
What like this
What are you thinking 30 55?
Yeah, yeah, no, I know I can respect but like what would be ideal for me to go into the dlc with you know
And I I got I value your guys's opinion
I feel like this looks good
Again, this 22 is bothering me. I wish it was 25
Um
But I'll survive
You should go without a weapon. Oh my god, you're so right queen
You going to dlc blind as I know
everything about the lore of the dlc, but I've never
and I know the
Boss fights, but I it's only some of them like all the remembrance bosses
I know about and only like I also fell asleep to a lot of the videos because I like to listen to them
um
Lots of faith up it's in dlc
I've heard but I also want to play like I've always been a faith builds and I know
Ironic with the way I'm dressed right now, but I really want to try the int builds
The lc is so easy. It's the easiest you'll see. Okay. I'm gonna go with this
I
Um, I'm actually gonna just try to get another
Okay, I don't have runes like I thought I did. Oh wait, do I?
I'm just gonna use all my little
Think about I'm gonna see if I can get like one more level
Wait talk do I not have what do I do? I don't have stuff equipped
Oh, I need a two-handed that's why
What is happening I forget how to play
Oh my god
I'm like, how do I shoot air? I haven't played in a week and I'm like, how do I play?
Okay, I'm gonna level actually
How many how much more do I need?
And okay, let me kill him one more time. Let me sit down
No, I don't really care about you. I only grab this so I could farm so I don't really care about using this
What is the serpent bow? I don't remember
Hey, oh
Come here little burb. Thank you. It's so sweet
Because I don't like to go in just anything like a fight with a lot of runes
Uh
It's my character's pants. What about it? Oh, what the heck? Why are my pants like that?
Why am I isn't my weight is it the weight? Why are they like that?
Why was I
Why was I not wearing any pants? I don't know what did she bet than you do
What what staff
Oh my god, level 282
I'm role-playing right now that I wouldn't have any pants at all
Lissat staff. Where is Lissa? Is that dlc when you guys recommend a weapon?
Please tell me if it's dlc or not because I don't know all the base game up weapons either
Okay, I was checking if I was gonna fat roll
Oh
I think somebody recommended that before
Let me just walk off the cliff
My cost more fp I'm not gonna bother with that. I'm I'd rather spend the time getting some sort of staff from the dlc
um, but yes, I have moon veil and I have
the meteorite staff
Then I do I already have Lissat staff because I just I went through the sorcery
town
Do I have that?
I don't know either the staff have lost is that what you meant
No, that's boost and visibility sorcery, which no one uses
I have to beat the boss for it. I didn't beat the there's a boss there
What
You mean in kaolin there is a
Wait a second. Wait a second. Wait a second. Wait a second. What why did I not notice that?
This one you mean selling a town of sorcery
What
Oh
Raina, are you puking? I feel like I just heard you spit up girl. Where's you at?
Let me check on that sound like someone was puking. Oh, I love cats. They just like puke everywhere
What are you doing?
You puke? Oh, no you're chewing on a box
I
Got on cat TV for the keys
Raina loves cat TV
You're watching chipmunks
Ow
I am like, you know, like how you'll wake up
I mean sometimes almost just as you hear the first note of your alarm
If I hear the first note of Raina puking, I am wide awake
It was me who I threw up
All right. Yeah, let's let's go get that boss then. Why not?
Let's go get that boss. Why didn't you guys mention this before?
I'm surprised you guys didn't mention it when I was getting the night comet
Where where where where is it?
Oh, fuck
I don't I said I don't like back seating unless I ask for help and I'm clearly asking for help go left. Okay. Fuck off
Something tells me it's over here
Oh, yeah
Do do do how do I play? Oh god
Oh frick no Raina
You bitch you bitch I want that whip. Oh stop canceling me out
Oh my god, no
No, no
Oh
Whoa, why is her reach on that so far?
You bitch, maybe I should lock on maybe I should do that. Maybe that would be a good idea
Oh
Oh you whatever
What
Please stop running away Jesus that took way too many flasks
Uh
Give me that flowing sword
Wait, I thought you said there's a staff. Oh, I found it
Raina are you singing the song of your people?
What is the whip skill with
Because I want this would be very I was like tempted to do a cosplay run
Oh, I see
Okay, interesting that would be a good whip
You need to confess confess
Matter with the whip doesn't yeah, that's why I was trying to figure out
I'm trying to think of
Or maybe it's
I don't know
I don't freaking know
I don't like the noise that it makes
I'm a sucker for a sickle though. Although. It's not really a sickle. It's just a goofy looking sword if you really look at it
Oh, it's your first time here. Hello, welcome
My name is she be cotton mom. I am a part of indulge gen one of velar
Um, I'm your favorite girl failure dom and I love to kind of dress up my model and role play and do wacky voices
And I have three cats and they all are very chatty
Um
I tried doing the light attack I didn't I didn't really do anything
I'm literally like
Oh, thank you, authority tight. Oh, maybe I should two hands. You're right. You're right. You're right
What the I am I stupid?
Thank you, authority for the gift it yippie
Again, I don't remember how to play either
Make sure you say thank you if you got something
Hi, Toma. Hi my sweet monkey
Everybody say hi to Toma
How much damage does this do I know I don't scale with it and it's not lovely at all, but I kind of want to see
Yeah, I definitely would put an ash of war on this bad boy. Hello, I need a guinea pig
I hear hello
Oh
Sorry, oh this does not do a lot. Ow. Ow. Ow
Oh, oh broke your stance though. Oh, uh, give me a moment. Give me a moment. Oh
Oh, this is I like the range on it though. Oh freaking stop
The animation is absolute trash though
Uh, I don't like that animation length
So I'm gonna go rest at the side of grace
Although I could have just gone to the other side of the grace, but you know, I don't think things sir
Does this not have a lot of ash of war and well, let me put an ash of war on it then I'm not going to use this
It has a very good hit, but I'd rather
um
Well, what is this? No, it's I was like, what is this cop count as a curbsword? Oh my god my chummy
What's the difference between this and this
Is it called sorcery scaling? Okay
Hmm
Hmm. Hmm. All right
Sick. Does this have a special thing where it like boosts?
Oh, I was hoping I was hoping I had some sort of passive effect
Um read the item description
And
Oops
How do I do that? I forget
Can I slap a skill on it? I don't know
I am pressing square
Is it this button
No, no that's not it
Again, I'm using a PlayStation controller when I think you're supposed to be using like a uh
Watch them. I call it. Is it this? No
I'll never know guys
No, that just lets me equip it wait, why is it oops I didn't mean to do two steps
Oh my god, my tummy is hoarding
It's just me
Oh go through the inventory
How what the hell how do I why can't I see the item descriptions?
Oh, okay, it's square inventory. Okay. Yep. Yep. Yep
All right, hold on be right back my tummy horde
I'm dying my
Oh
You
Okay, I'm done fighting for my life
I can't believe you guys let me eat ice cream
I realize I should have put up a BRB screen
I didn't do anything that was your idea
Yeah, I told them where they fed me ice cream against my will
Yeah, I fought tooth and nail guys the cult
Odd can I be like TMI real quick?
It was like
I thought I was like dying
Like my insides that were being like flushed out like I was just like
Turning to sludge from the inside
But I realized as I was looking I was like it's from the red velvet cake
Raina come here
I also took a while because Raina decided because I was bent over like Shinji and Raina decided to sit on my back
And so I had to wait for her to get off
Yeah, it was it looked like scarlet rot
It's all your fault
So technically is your fault because it was the cake I was like
Oh
Really? Oh, that's a good idea. Toma. I didn't know that why would it turn? Oh because it probably like absorbs everything
Raina come stug
One of the Raina will probably lay on my lap rather than the cat cam
Anyways, let us commence
Hey, it could have been pro no you guys told me to do that too
You guys are bad influence on me. I'm just gonna say
Just gonna say
Oh, yeah, no the ice cream is great
I'm scared to toot
You
Harlets are so mean I'm happy Toma understands
Yeah, for shame for shame
It's ridiculous. What do you guys even talk about when I was gone?
The one time I don't want to be sheepies cats
She doesn't come back I'm gonna fade away like I got Thanos snap
Oh that
Oh
Offending staff of loss will give you a Thursday at the end of the month. Uh, that'd probably be if I was going like full sorcery
Yeah, they weren't gonna survive. Yeah, you're
She is built to survive
Don't miss you the most
The fossil
I'm waiting for boomie to come back because when I got up he got up too
All right, what am I doing?
Was I resting here or something
I
Guys, no, I don't have anything
I I've literally been let me go to this. I've been speed running
Wait, why did I have this marked?
I don't remember uh, I've been speed running
Trying to get to the dlc. So I haven't
like I'm not even
Gonna bother with like the consecrated snow fields and like the mount top of the giants
Um, however, I do have to go see
Let's uh
Got that staff. Let's see how good it do
Um
Yeah, we're gonna go beat a homeless man. Um, I
Should upgrade it. Is this an upgradeable weapon? Is the staff upgradeable?
I don't know if I have any I'm assuming it takes like
I hate I wish the round table would kind of just be floating the corner
The meteorite one is the only one you can't
No, yeah, no, you can't upgrade the meteorite one
Hugue
Wrong way
Oh
Finally hi
Uh, I don't have any ghost glove work
Under a rock I was
I
Do not have a three
Frick
Okay, let's go fight gold free
Okay
So I can get that
Watch them or call it. Uh, where is more god? No, not more god. I accidentally already got more god's shackle
Where is mogs shackle?
I feel like it it's over here, isn't it? I didn't get any of the sights of grace on the way
So I'm just gonna start
Yeah, all right
Oh, yeah, that's right because I have to kill his little ghost
Fuck I hate that. Why did I sit back down? I didn't mean to hello
Uh, we all know that I can't do direction
Oh
I don't have to kill his I thought his ghost was in the sewers and I have to kill it together
I don't forget remember I when I killed mogu before I just killed him
And when I say I killed him I had summoned some other players and they is their comet his ass
So
I can't remember where stuff is
To kill mogu you just need to kill the one a mogu in palace what really
How detailed instructors do you want? Um
Wait, why is that two then what's one? What did I set as one?
What the heck what was I setting up over here?
Oh
I like need to remove these because they're gonna bother me. Oh there it is. It's because I was doing that
Where's the three is in that direction?
Yeah, I went to him for stuff
I
Wanted the shackle
Ladies and gentlemen, we are an hour and a half and I am just starting
Please buckle your seatbelts it will be a turbulent for light
I do not get up unless the seatbelts sign is turned off
This I did not think he could reach me
I
Will do this on foot
Yeah
It's funny
That people just have like runes on their head
All right, I'm lily is gonna run past everybody
I could get the fire monk
Set to be more fire resistant
To him
I feel like something drops here I can't remember
Or it's the guy on the horse
It is indeed two guys on the horse
Hello
No
Stop
I just want to get the golden seeds over here, bro in the grace
Sit down oh well he's going back it doesn't matter
The eternal cray
Uh, you should get the lean flavor. It's very good
Can I do I have enough I can't remember
I think I need three now. Oh boomi's back
No, I don't have enough I need four oh you're terrible
King of the graze king of an old
Let me uh get the booby cam going
Why are you facing that way why can't you let everybody see you spinning you around
You spin me right around baby right around perfect
Dude I'm just drinking my gamer subs this is the mango flavor like a boomi the new fancy cup
You
Look at this man look at this
It's
I'm sorry
Beautiful cat. Oh, thank you. Yeah, he's a good boy. Sometimes mostly he's a menace. Can I have a kiss? No, no kiss
He's looking at his tail like stop touching me
Has booby done anything in the stream actually he's been pretty good. It's been all right
He's
It's cuz he wants to face this direction. He doesn't want to face the other direction. So you get boomi, but I'm sorry
Sam boomi
You take after your mama
Not me. I'm say so woman
I'm the most say so streamer that I've ever streamed before
What am I doing here
Okay, I have to go over here
Yeah
What I thought I got rid of this
Why is there
Sorry, it bothers me if I see stuff. That's not so there's a there's a one
Okay, cool, cool, cool, cool. Okay. I just making sure it's the right one
All right, then the freaking gargoyle bro is gonna show up in a second
Oh
I came in like a wrecking ball
Michael fight him
Perfect
Why are you still following me? Where are you? Okay left
Go away
Put these foolish ambitions to rest
Is he
He's chasing after me
How do they just like send themselves like how do they do that? Is there where's this freaking grace?
I'm going the wrong way. Anyways, it's over here right there. I'm so dumb
He's still following me
I think he disappeared
Yeah, how do they how's their how are their astral projection projecting
How do they astral project with health
I'm just breaking everything wait, I thought it's yeah in that direction
Again, I haven't played Elden Ring in about like
Since it came out
So I don't remember everything is
I like forget like all the late game stuff for some reason
Wait, I feel like something is shot at me. What is it? I forget. Oh, that's what it is. It's this freaking dude. I thought
Where is it?
Oh, it's that bridge over there. All right
Isn't there a death bird? I can't recall where the death bird is
Pretty sure there's a death bird like right over here
If I remember correctly
Excuse him. Oh my god. Well, that's awkward. No
There's so many freaking giants
Oh, I didn't think that would hit me. This is not worth it. Maybe
I
No, I was hoping it wouldn't hit me
I'm right next to you. I'm right here
Am I gonna lock on and no
Killing you in particular
Why did he jump up like that?
Keep running run. Oh frick. Oh frick. I forgot about you. I forgot about the da
Wait, I didn't equip my staff for some reason
What why isn't it showing up?
Hello, oh
Uh question mark. I am confused. All righty then. Um, I'm stuck in the street
Okay
Why why am I even trying?
It's funny when I first did my own playthrough. I um, just cheat. I felt like I cheesed every boss with um
You gotta have a copyface key. Uh, yes, I know I need to kill him to get past the door
Um, I just like use the black knife on everybody and I just maxed it out
And it was very effective because it was effective against most
So it's like god's good apostles and shit
Why isn't it letting me use the staff
Am I missing something
Why I was literally clicking this
And it didn't do it. You guys saw it like
Do it. I'm not I'm not going crazy
Oh, I should have I didn't equip that that's fine. Uh, I don't even know this is effective against you
Nope, it's not
So
Damn
Nope
So
What three times
Whoa, I pressed B
No, I thought I could time that right. Okay, I can get him. I'm not gonna summon
Why would I summon I can beat him myself. I don't need to summon
You think I should use the meteorite stuff I'll try it
I
Got Zigglin some stuff
Let me just
Does he see me
Damn it
I
Damn it, I was hoping I could creep up behind him
What are you doing? Oh, I'm not paying attention
Oh, I'm sorry. I'm like not paying attention
That's not you lied. I'd rather use the meteorite staff. I mean the moon veil
What how did he that's weird you guys saw me roll out of that
Oh, I rolled into that it's fine. Let me pick up my rooms
Can you stop
Why am I getting I'm I'm doing it at the right time. I'm I'm doing things at the right time
I maybe I should be jumping instead of rolling
This I can just kind of really step out of the way of
You
Are you gonna go fourth time? Yeah, you already fucking bitch
Oh, you fucking bitch
Why did you do it five times?
Stop with the horse
I don't
Oh my god
I'm sick of your horse. I'm sick of your horse
I'm out of fp
Oh
No
Bro, let me live
Oh
Wait, did I swear
No, why would I use it I'm not gonna use the spirit summons. No, no, no, no, no, no, no
A little bit damn
I'm say so I'm say so I'm say so I'm say so I'm say so
I wish I was near a side of grace, but to change to something else wait, can I uh, do you like a magic limp blade moment?
I'm too far away
How much damage will that do to you? Oh, okay
Oh
Oh too early
Oh fuck you
Oh
Have you found me scato trees bros bro, I'm literally still in the base game. What are you talking about?
No cost spell spam, yeah
Let's try it. Let's try it. Let's try it
Oh shit, that actually was helpful
Oh
How did that miss
Yeah, I jumped too early. Oh, it's enough with the fucking horse
I thought the animation wouldn't take that long
I
Damn it
Oh
Oh, you stupid horse, that's gonna kill me. This is gonna kill me. Yeah
Yeah, these are in the in my opinion, these are easier than a tree sentinel
I think they have dragon powers because of the red lightning
Yeah, it's a draconic sentinel
Uh, let's try that again. I like that this opening with the spam because it kind of staggers him
No
Oh fucking mother, I mean praise the lord
No, I didn't mean to cast
I'm so close to death. I'm so close to death. Please enough with the horse
Oh, I was like hoping oh, please stop
Stop
Please stop
Oh my god
Why do I feel like me taking drinking is taking longer than usual. Oh my god
What
Yeah, the horse is like the spam
He will usually spam if you're well, I noticed that that was that much was obvious. I knew when I got a certain distance
He spams it
Boomi you are so cute right now. I wish you guys could see his face. Uh, what if I
I want to creep I want to creep up on him
I thought that was a grace. I got really excited. I was like, there's not a grace this close
So
Oh
Come on
The plastic bag did you a number on him
It's might take me a while
Damn, that was good. Yeah, that was good damage. That was good damage
Uh, you can't
Repost him. Can you though? You can't repost the draconic sentinel
Right, I can't recall
Okay, you're right. Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay. So because I I literally ran to the front when I could have been spamming like to get blood built
Uh, uh, fuck. I'm not here. I'm not here
Well, I might lock down these fucking birds
I'm not here. I'm not here. I'm not here. I don't see shit. You don't see shit, bitch. You don't see shit. You don't see shit
I'm not here
I'm just a creepin
Creeping by you
Sneaking
Sneaking by you
I
I'm trying to roll backwards
And for some odd reason I'm just like getting locked in the animation
Oh
The tweet fine, I'll tweet
My eye is twitching
Oh
Excuse me part 10 more. Oh, no, I meant to uh, I meant to mute that. Oh my god
Oh, I'm letting you like of me. I'll never recover
All right
Ending it all in Aldenry
Um
Nope, that's not what I meant to look at
I know epi boomy. He's all curled up in a little like
His eyes are open actually
There you go
No, no, go back to sleep
Go back to sleep
Bro, who are you looking at? He's looking at nothing. He's he's even
Half and me had a rat cam that'd be funny
Yeah, I used to have a pat cam a lot um in my pl
And um
I realized a lot of people really liked it. So I wanted to bring it back once I felt more comfortable with y'all
What
Oh
No, I keep flummoxing it
They move around too much understandable boomy's kind of just chilling right now
Oh
Okay, he
Is a gentleman and he bows the draconics tree sentinel
Oh, oh
Oh my
Hey, you you didn't hear but he made a little squeak when he stretched he was like
That's because he's cute doesn't mean he's a menace. Don't be fooled. Don't be fooled your honor
He is not who he says he is you honor didn't many a serial killer lure in unsuspecting victims
Let's just sit and look at him for a moment
So I can like spam a few things right off the rip like
Yeah, okay
Okay, nope I I did it too early
No
I did it too early and why am I getting the timing wrong? Why am I getting the timing wrong?
Hey, can't you just walk past him? No
If you think I would have walked past him do you think I would have walked past him
Don't you think I'm fighting this boss for a reason?
Don't cry talk it up
Maybe glit blit oh when he staggered that's a good idea. That's a good idea
Since I can't reposs this motherfucker, which is ridiculous
Oh, why did I do that?
Oh
I'm out
I'm good. Oh, I'm not good
Oh
I timed that wrong
I can't get my fp
Oh, okay now I have time
You
You know that wall is yellow I need to kill him to get something that I need to get past it
Dang that was good though. That was good. That was good
He's not a hard boss. He's not a hard boss. He really isn't
I
Boomi is snug as a bug in a rug
Usually like I killed him in like five seconds because again I had the black knife
When I got him before so
Oh, why didn't I how
I'm so close to you. Why are you spamming that? Why am I only just sheathing why?
Since when was the aoe so a frickin large
Oh
I'm sorry, boomi. I'm sorry. Hi. Hi baking
That's frickin face
You
Are you going
Why you he's leaning so much
Bro you're gonna fall off my desk
He can be a little darling indeed. I didn't mean to do that
I am going to beat them without ashes
I am going to I am gonna be him without summoning
I kind of want to level my moon veil some more
I almost I'm debating whether or not to max it out, but I don't know if even that's
Point wow look at the freaking colors and the lighting
No
I'm out of a pee
How did he hit me from the far
Are you stuck
I
Eat my booty eat it eat it eat it
Nice
I
Just had to lock in just had to lock in boys just had to lock in
Uh, I swear to god. I thought a side of grace was right here, but I suppose not
I was right here
How many tries did I take like eight eight attempts ten?
You're to confess your sins
Welcome
Okay, I should probably sit down me let me pop a squat
Pop a squat and confess
All right, now we got a fight
And what's his face
Can upgrade your flask. Oh, you're right
Let me go do that
Sometimes I forget things
I'm speaking of witch
Uh
Yeah, because I have comet and I have night comet
Because night comet is good with the staff a loss because it's semi invisible and it boosts like invisibility stuff
I
Start from the beginning
Yeah, that's me. You're probably wondering how I got so sinful
Huh, I bet you thought I was gonna run off, huh?
You're wrong
Hello, oh, I'm like that was taken a bit
I
Da da da da gonna go fight what's his face Godfrey
Moink
Hello
Oh no
Clary no the condensation clary
I feel like something's gonna jump out at me
Wait, did I go the wrong way?
Wait, what the heck this is this is normal lindel
I
Went the right way took to Godfrey again, I don't remember
I couldn't I thought he was right after that like directly after but I am incorrect
Um, I know I can oh, yeah, there's a summoning pool right there
Uh
Did you have royal capital? I'm just gonna speed run past these little bubble dudes
Now
Let me just
No, no, I don't need to kill Godfrey not God. I know his ghost. Where is Godfrey's ghost?
Same way I could have sworn his ghost was closer
God damn it. All right, I'm gonna fuck with the other fucker
Yeah, he's amazing piercing boys shit
Oh, no
Moke shackle no, I want the talisman pouch and well and I'm getting moke shackle. So I think
I didn't get to the urtary sanctuary
Oh
Oh, I fucking hate the lindel knights
Okay, which is closer the shackle
Or Godfrey's ghost
Oh my back cracked, I don't know if you guys heard that
About the same distance
Yeah, that's why I was gonna get morgot too
So do I just literally just have to clear lindel
I do like lindel it is one of my favorite areas
Although I do distinctly remember crying because I kept dying to this one night
Okay, well, I guess we'll just speed run through this then
I do want to kill you though
No, don't throw shit at me
Oh
Thing is I can't remember where anything is
Because I should have just I shouldn't even gone through this way I should have gone through the city
I
Should have gone by the rooftops. Are you gonna chase me? Oh, I missed. Are you gonna kill me? Yeah
Well, I'm gonna go get my thing of ops, I will go get my
My rooms
It's behind the two shrimps the scrimps
Your song sucks
Oh
What the frick I'm so stupid
It's this way oh
Anyways, we're fine
Hello, hello, hello, excuse me, uh, uh, pardon, excuse
Huh, why didn't she fall from fall damage? You know why didn't she die from fall damage?
Yeah, I kept dying to this dude right here
Because I I went from the rooftop I went from the rooftops to get over here
Uh, oh my god, he's gonna chase me
Stop
Go away
Stranger danger, why are you walking towards me?
I really don't want to fuck with you right now. I'm waiting for you to de-aggro so I can try to get the side of grace that's nearby
Oh my god, you're not going to
Maybe if I go all the way over here
Are you preaching me? Yeah, I do have enough
I don't need to go over here. Do I know this is where the sewers are I think um, but why are you still?
Bruh, how are you not de-agroed yet? Okay now you are I'm gonna let you walk away
His shoes whack his hair whack
His fit whack actually I remember I did farm that armor set before
Where the frick did he go? Oh, he's right there
There is a side of grace on this side somewhere
And then there is the ur-tree
Uh, no, there's a dude in that place
I remember getting his weapon
Right
Yeah, that's the another crucible knight, I think
Yeah, yeah, he doesn't have a good shield. I never did it like a shield sword build though. Uh, let's see
Ur-tree should fall from the sky when I come over here. I presume
Where even eat is it jumping from?
Is it just spawn out of nowhere? We're we're like
Where is it waiting? Oh, see, yeah
That's the sewers down there
Excuse me
Okay, here we go. Perfect. Don't you fucking do it
I am busy go go reset
What what are you doing here?
Now I can set it on fire
I was really never your maiden
I offered you an accord and I'm taking it away
We all know who you really are Glomide Queen
I
Like how she just like gives me the ability when she could have done that before
Melania it's always an ASMR mode
Thanks see you girly pop. Uh, it's been cool
All right, let me kill this tree
Melatonin
Are you at
Heller
I want to see it fall
Wait, doesn't it like spawn over there
After you walk by it the first time no, okay. I'm tripping
I want to see you teleport into the sky
Wait, there you are
Oh
Why am I not locked onto you
My nose is itchy
I forgot I shouldn't get too close for that. Oh, no, no, no, these I can just go grab my runes
You
Like goth melly melly
meldon
Madness cracked on she I yeah, sometimes I just like this associate and I become one with my
My true Elden Ring self
I am gonna kill this just because it's actually let me go use my room
So I don't have to keep worrying about grabbing them
Oh, I'm not going to use that well actually I am gonna use that
Uh
How much do I need oh perfect, let's put that
Into a bigger I'll start working up my very although I just really want to make this 25
So, you know what we're making that 25 eventually eventually we'll get to 25 for endurance
I
Because it's also bothering me as well. All right, uh, what do I have here for you?
I don't know what's that's the damage on this
Hmm
Okay
Okay, these really don't bother you that much
Let me just whoop-a
I
What the frick I was I didn't press my forward stick fast enough, uh
If at all, uh
If I get like really in him
Oh, I thought I could jump I didn't
Whoa
Oh, wait every good I can use my flask. Oh my god. I'm so silly
Oh
I did not get the timing right
I'm so stupid. I'm not paying attention to the timing. I was so focused on
When he was gonna swing that I forgot that it goes earlier for the little
Beams of light. I'm just standing there just like
Uh
Seems like the comet was helpful
Let me get my 3k runes very important guys very important
Very important
Is that gonna reach him? Oh it did
You aren't you staggered
Nope
What
I
Oops
I'm trying to jump why can't I stand up please
Oh my god
Who am I locking on to
It doesn't matter I'm gonna kill you in five seconds
I thought he was gonna die when I hit him and so it would cancel out that attack it didn't
Oh, it didn't I got too I got too greedy. I got too greedy. I got too greedy
I got too greedy
Hold on. Let me while he's sleeping
I realize I should have spun you the other way
Oh
All right, sorry go back to sleep. I'm gonna make you I'm just gonna make you dizzy
He readjust to get back in the right spot
He's so funny
Okay, sorry, let me kill this guy. I'm I'm I'm messing around I'm messing around
I gotta I gotta be serious, you know bros
I kind of want to
What are you doing?
Oh
Why is it taking me forever to get up?
Why am I not why am I just
What is happening? Why can't I use my actual war? Oh my god
I'm I'm literally I don't know why I'm rolling when I don't have to you
Okay
I I'm doing the timing I'm doing the timing wrong. I'm nine
Uh, what did I just do
I accidentally made everything too big guys
Guys what did I just do? No, I didn't mean to take a screenshot. What did I just do?
Oh no
What did I just do
Guys I made everything so big I can't even see the game. It's just a two black screens
And I can kind of see
I can kind of see the chat
And then we'll let me get out of it
Um
Oh
Is there like a zoom thing
Is there a zoom feature because I think I accidentally turned that on
I
Because I can't see anything it's just switching across my stream guys help
I can't see anything I might take a picture and show you what my my screen looks like right now
I can see just the chat
I
Oh, you're right. I did hold on
What the hell
Oh
My god, I'm like in full screen and I can't get out of it
Guys, where did you go? No, I can't see the chat
Guys
Oh no, I don't know how to get out of this
What did I press?
Do it again
How now I can only see my model in a black screen
No, I'm taking screenshots on accident
Oh
Okay, well I have to google this I can't have to google this for my phone
One second
Super zoomed in windows
A magnifier tool the window and escape keys
Okay, I fixed it
It's fine. We're good. We're good. It's fine. We're amazing. We're doing wonderful. We're having a great time
Okay, there we go
No, I can't oh won't let me use my okay, there we go
Everything's under control should be kind of cute. No
I don't know what you're talking about. I am not cute. I am just she be
And she be wants some skills
I got skill gummies skill gummies
Oh, I'm gonna get some skill gummies
I should get up you guys want to see look at my look at my
Uh
It's my slipper
Stop trying to tag my slipper. Why are you sniffing where I put it?
I never had these before
There's girls with their gummies
They're pretty good
I couldn't find so my favorite gummies are this the um
The ones that I added to my throne before the star mix. Those are my favorite the haribo star mix
um
But these I wanted to try something new gummies are my favorite type of candy
Can you get one? Yeah, what color you want?
What color you want?
Oh
There's no more left of the yellow
Movie's like no
There's one left. No, I don't see a little one. What are you talking about? That's orange. That's orange
There's only purple green and red
Hmm
Whoa
That's not yellow it's orange
I just remembered I didn't kill him
Oh
What that was not
I'm stuck
I'm stuck. I'm definitely stuck now
Uh, I can't get out of here. Oh no, I can I jumped
I need to heal fast
Oh, I jumped too early
Okay
No, I just stick my hand in I eat what there's what's there. I don't pick colors
I'm not that type of autism
Not even autistic
So
It's a grape lemon green apple strawberry and orange honestly again, just like regular skittles. They all taste the same
Are you sure about that
Ah
How many times the animation is delayed I thought I was out of that
Okay, okay
Uh, I didn't mean to do that
Are you gonna jump nope
I'm not
Why does that kill me usually I'm really good at dodging that when I killed uh when I fought the urge tree
dude, um
Before I was able to dodge it a lot easier
Some kind of sting
Yeah, I do like holy magic. That's why I had the halo scythe
La la la la
What are you doing
I
Good
I messed up the timing of that
I want to be able I like was watching people like jump to dodge stuff and I want to be able to do that
I
Just walked into that
Sorry, I'm like, I'm generally just like not trying right now. I'm just fucking around. I want you to jump again
Damn it
Can you jump oh I got that time
Yeah
Yeah, no damn it. I was caught in the animation of slicing you up
At least that those all missed because he knocked me down
Yeah
Yeah, I did what okay, maybe that just doesn't work for that. Yeah, maybe it only works when he stomps
I wish I could roll out of the way instead of you know, like slicing you
What oh my god, I'm so happy I healed
Let's get down to business
I like how the one I wasn't trying on is the one that actually killed him that makes sense
That makes a lot of sense
Let me go heal
This is our DLC or a dawn
Hello, hi, are you winning? I just bleaked on my hand. That's nice. All right. Um
Let's go to the sewers first because we're like right there anyways
I
Pops it up and down oh and all around. Don't you fucking do it?
They're here, right? I know there's the worm
Not to sewers
I'm not gonna bother him. He's just doing his own thing. You know, we're not gonna bother him
Guilty gear parkour not this way. What do you mean not this way?
You said the sewers
You need to go down a well. Oh, okay. I'm gonna die of these rats. So it doesn't matter. Oh, just kidding
Frick
Where's the well? Oh
That's that's I know where the well is
The well is over here though. I need to go up the ladder
Hi, let me get this grace
Isn't there an evader like around here? Oh, I'm near Fia's bed
Oh
Hmm now I can dress some little death bed dress
Like oh, he's just like really just really bummed. She's not here. Um
Enjoy Dark Souls
Yeah, it's like that one dude. Where is the well I actually ever I know
I picturing it in my mind. I cannot remember where it is though
I
Should I attempt to kill this guy
No, oh, it's not very nice
I remember I died to that dude like 50 times before what the hell was that?
Church, I mean if uh, okay, thank you. I will try that
Let me sit down. Does he respawn if he does? I don't think he does because he dropped an item
Exit church jump over rabble
I don't think I can jump over this rabble, but I knew to get it on that side, right
Oh
Frick I do need to get on that side. Yeah, let me just oh, you're still here
Oh, I didn't drop that. Oh, I can't teleport without killing you
You have crazy good boys stop it
Oh
There's definitely a way to parkour out of this side. I don't know why I can't do maybe if I just jump down here
Oh, okay got some rats
Oh, not the spiders
No, I went the wrong way
How are you doing here?
I
I'm pretty sure I'm near another boss. Oh, no, I hate these. I hate these. I hate these so they actually jump scare me
They freak me the freak out
I hate them so freaking much
Yeah, that's a strange variable
Oh, I can't see
And I'm behind the Lindell soldiers, right
This is a big big guy
Too bad he dead
Somebody gonna clean that up
That's big head piece those black
Bags actually invoke paranoia and fear unaware. I'm sorry. Oh, I hate it. I hate it. I hate it. I hate it
I hate it
The walls over here, right
It's on that rubble if you go over that rubble, right?
To my left. Oh
Found it. What this? Oh fuck die. I'm surprised I didn't wake you up
All right, the fuck is gonna jump out at me
Die come here
Oh, you're so lucky I'm gonna getcha
Wait, oh I can open this I was like, but wait
Oh
Yeah, there's a lot of paths all roads lead to lindell
All right, I'm not looking forward to this
Not at all I feel like I feel like I don't have any cookbooks or anything. So I don't have okay. Please get off this freaking ladder
So I don't have any like poison stuff
Although there's not poison in this water
I'm waiting for something to drop out at me
I can't see anything
Subterranean pooping grounds
So I'm gonna have to be right in the city because it's serious because I was looking for something to carry on
Yeah
No get away from me
Oh, I thought you're one of those poop dudes
Just wasting fp
Did she just dodge me
Oh
Someone's pissing down here. Oh, oh didn't see you there. Oh, I'm not locked on
Whoa, just waste fp on some rats
I
Was locked in a rubber room
Yeah, the shunning ground. Oh, what the fuck are you? I hit you from here. Oh, I can
I don't need fp though
I hear something screeching at me
Anything up here with me? No, uh, what about magic lymph late? How do you feel about that?
No, what okay, what about rock sling? How do you feel about that?
Okay, what about the comet? How do you feel about that? All right, you don't like that more
Uh, you got a lot of blight going on
I'm gonna wait for you to get away from the ladder because that's just not fair
I wish I could jump to this rope come over here
Is he de agro? Okay de agroed
Me heal
Oh
Freeze damage on charge spells do I
I don't think I do
No
Yeah, I don't have a lot I don't I don't have anything because I haven't I've literally been just trying to get to the dlc
That's not fair you can't I just got here. I just I just got here. I can't even lock on no
No, that didn't do shit to you
Oh, whoa
What the fuck was why there are two of you and you got me back to the corner that's not fair
Oh, he's not even agroed though
Why do I have no blood build up on you? Why do I have no bleed? Why are there two of you just fucking kicking me?
I mean freaking freaking freaking
Yeah, the god-free icon. Yeah
Where's the god-free icon?
Grace's path. Oh
Frick
Oh, I didn't know there was a hand there
Oh
Never got get off the ladder get off the ladder
Wait what the first is a ladder
Where's the ladder
Bro, I'm just dumb right now
That's right there
It doesn't even matter it doesn't even matter I just went back to where I was I'm just gonna
I
I don't even know if that was the right spot
Okay
Is it an everglow? Okay, I'm in the wrong place
I
Don't talk back to Toma
I don't want to appreciate this ass
I'm just trying my best she knows it. I know it. We all know it
All right, let's go to this freaking oh freak
I didn't mean to go down there
I didn't even mean to heal
I
I'm getting frustrated because I literally just want to get to the freaking DLC dude and I keep going the wrong way
And I keep having to pick up stuff on the way that I do need
In the end
It's taking so long
No, because then the worms gonna pop up if I go over there
Oh my god
This tree
I
Where's this damn well, I'm not going in there. It's just a bunch of dudes. Sorry pardon
Pick up whatever the hell this is. Oh you guys are all gonna wake up
I won't grab stuff over here
Well, I'm here might as well
I was no long near nowhere near that attack
No, I saw you leave now let me go
You guys can't climb so dude, where was the stupid well
I
Hate like one thing I'd have a terrible sense of direction and where like I don't remember a lot of things with things look the same
So it's hard for me
Don't fall off. I fell off. Uh, stop locking on
Getting irritated getting irritated getting irritated
I
Don't want to look at the worm
The other side of the bridge where I jump over here where the worm is then that's gonna attack me
I
Can't tell for it. How did you get over here, dude? How did you even get over here?
The opposite of where the worm is at but it's I that's right here
And I can't go this way because then there's just dudes in here with nothing good how I
Can I please just please please Jesus Christ
I can't even I'm trying to go back
To the grace but someone's aggroed on me and I don't know why
I
There are dude in this room. No, I'm not fucking with you. I mean freaking with you
I'm climbing you fool. How did you get up here? Why aren't you climbing? Why did you pause?
So it was over here, where did I get
Because I remember I was trying to jump around I was over here and I couldn't get on that side
And then I had to kill this dude
How how
I
Jumped on a roof. Where is the roof that I jumped on?
And trying to retrace my steps, but I also have a bad memory
Oh
Using my cat to de-stress
That's housing wrong
His head
Good luck
Oh big yawn. Can I get a lick?
Fuck
My nails
Oh
You're so soft, why are you so soft big man? You've been using a new conditioner
You got that dog what you
Oh, I went to the wrong one
I don't know why I I thought I was at the avenue but like anything I did it
I showed everybody your bomb
Let's open that dude
Oh, hi boy enjoyer
Thank you
Welcome back
Gash in the month of mams. Yeah, it's really awesome. I see that like he came
Oops, just a 40
So
Why is it locking on I don't want to lock on that
Enemy that
What do you that's just rude of you, it's crazy that everybody's just trying to kill you in this game
No
No, no, there's a bunch there's a bunch. No, no, no, no, there's a bunch
No, no, no, no, no, no, no
No, I don't like it. I don't like it. I don't like to get rid of it get rid of it. Oh, this is a rubble
Guys, I'm scared. Oh, they gave me the heebie-jeebies just freaking twitched. I don't know if you guys just saw me go like that
I don't like those noises
How did you hit try to hit me I'm scared
Look at the little I can
See it see it. How do I see it? I'll see it
Guys, I'm blind between the houses
Guys, I'm anxious I'm having a stressy girl moment
I am regressing
I am regressing how it wasn't so easy for me to get here before
It is by the stinky man, I don't want to do it. I'm stressing me out
I see it. Oh, my god
Oh, I don't make them I don't make them I don't make them
Are you serious
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no
Sorry, it was a visceral reaction. I just really don't like those
I
What
What just exploded behind me
Hmm. No, she the rats freak me out. I thought it was them
Why can't I reach
You
Hmm
No
No, I don't like it
Oh
And it's not like I'm not even raging
Like I'm not mad. I'm just uncomfortable for summary. I'm just feeling very uncomfortable
I
Never finished the sewer thing because I hate the sewer thing
I'm gonna eat some cake
Oh, I accidentally dropped my controller
It's like I'm I'm stressed
More than anything
I
This is a leftover cake that I see
All right, I want to give boomi a smooch
My cake on your head
I
Don't
I'm like, I'm looking stuff up. No, I look up a lot of stuff. This isn't my first time
playing. I did a lot of research for the DLC, but I just haven't played in a really long
time, so I have a travel-sensory direction in games and outside of games. Yeah, the
stewards just really bother me. I'm just trying to get the shackle. I apologize, sometimes
I just have reactions like that. I swear I'm not autistic. I just want to eat the cream
cheese. It's more got shackle because I bought it other than its patches.
No, I already have Moog unlocked. I'm just trying to get the shackle, but thank you.
What the heck has happened to your hand? It'd be okay if you were. Thank you.
Yeah, sorry, Marget. I have Marget Marget. Again, I don't remember. Just to be him because
I know I'll probably need it just of how I am. I'm sorry. I'm sorry. I'm sorry. I'm
sorry. I'm just really kid-ish right now. I'm really sorry. I'll try to be more serious.
I'm just embarrassed. I'm just embarrassed. I'm just not going to even bother. I can't
calm down here. They can't help me. It doesn't matter. It doesn't matter. It doesn't matter.
I can't see. I can't see. I can't see. I can't see. I can't see. I can't see. I can't see. I can't see. I can't see. I can't see. I can't see. I can't see. I can't see. I can't see. I can't see. I can't see. I can't see. I can't see. I can't see. I can't see. I can't see. I can't see. I can't see. I can't see. I can't see. I can't see. I can't see. I can't see. I can't see. I can't see. I can't see. I can't see. I can't see. I can't see. I can't see. I can't see. I can't see. I can't see. I can't see. I can't see. I can't see. I can't see. I can't see. I can't see. I
can't see. I can't see. I can't see. I can't see. I can't see. I can't see. I can't see. A little ladder. I don't know where I
I
Don't know where it goes nobody knows
Go back
The side of crisis right there
One night was going to bed is it over here or is it back up the ladder
I
Can just climb the ladder guys I
Can hear them all around the ladder
Wait, what do you oh
Oh
I'm a big girl
The Lord will protect me I am one with the Lord
I
Especially don't tell us dudes
I'm not what
Oh
Oh, oh all right
This does indeed work. Oh
Which way do I go lobster do I go that way?
Or do I go that way
This makes me hungry for lobster I think I deserve a lobster after this
And you have to sexual no, but I generally can't I
Don't know why but it just like
It's like dip. I don't know. I can't really even explain it
I'm gonna wait for the lobster to go back around
We wear a sniper
Trying to see if I can lock but just going straight. Can you go the other way, please?
Oh
Frick oh no hiding. Oh, hi
Oh, God, I'm in a tube. I'm surrounded my nose is itchy. You're gonna shoot me aren't you?
Oh
Brother
Torrent, where are you?
Yeah, whatever this is. Oh, I got it
But I want my ruins
No, I want my runes. I want my runes. I want my runes. I want my runes
I'll take me five seconds. I'll take me five seconds. Don't worry about it. Don't worry about it. Don't worry about it
Oh
Okay, I fell like this
And we're going
To
Why did I do that I
There's so many sevens. Hey, how do I get back? Oh
How do I get back up wait, did I just see a ladder no
No, please
Please
My food is fighting back
No
Where is I don't get out of here guys follow the lights, okay
Aha
Ha ha ha ha don't shoot me don't shoot me
Where the fuck I am I mean frick
Oh
Interesting are you guys just gonna keep coming back? Oh
Okay, yeah
Any ghost glove word around here go for some ghost glove word
No
I don't know what the server does
Oh, I found out what it does
I
Don't even know where I am
There's a side of grease I am excited for that
No, I'm getting the ruins
It's fine. It's fine. Don't worry about it
Don't worry about it. Don't worry about it speed run speed run speed run
speeding run
Now speed run
Speed run speed run
It's fine
No
You
I'm thinking we're having a moment where there's something isn't going the way I want I'm just very upset
It's the control thing with the OCC
I'm sorry to wake you I need to hold your pouch for support
I
I see boomies emotional support pouch
Think I'm just PMSing mentally ill
Again I know give them as much
just don't make fun of me, that's all I ask, I don't make fun of you.
Where do I go now?
I'm the dragon queen.
Hey, what?
Wrong way, sweetie.
I don't know how he can lock on me when I'm not near them.
I'm sorry, I'm a big baby today.
I'm just embarrassed, because I'm supposed to be the big tough mad, I'm being a little weird.
Where am I going?
I have to do more.
It's hard trying to be tough all the time.
I've been very stressed, I'll be honest, I think that's what it is.
I don't think he would hit me, no.
So I think that's why I'm a big baby, I just want to be baby right now.
What's this?
I'm distracted by shiny, don't hit me.
I missed.
No.
Frick.
You can't, you can't come.
It's not allowed, you can't come over here.
No, no, go away.
It's not allowed, it's not allowed, it's not allowed, it's not allowed, it's not allowed, it's not allowed.
What a weird place to land.
Yeah, I honestly think that's it, I've just been stressed.
And I think I just really haven't accepted it, that I'm stressed.
Because I'm by myself, so I'm responsible for myself.
So I'm just kind of got to do things alone.
Is that the right way?
Was I going the right way? Is this the right way?
Oh, um, excuse me motherfucker, I thought you were asleep, so I left you alone.
Oh, okay, well, okay.
I was hoping I could dodge at a time.
Oh, stop, stop, stop, just stop, just stop.
Okay.
You still love me even when I'm a big baby?
I need a hug.
It's like, I can't even like go like play and just stop and pretend to be like big boss mad when I just don't have the mentality to do that.
How am I supposed to get higher than that?
Over here?
Hmm.
Okay, thank you.
Thank you for accepting all parts of me.
I accept all parts of you too.
Am I going to have to fight these guys? I just really don't want to.
I really don't want to.
Hmm.
Yeah, I saw the fucking coming.
666, that's a double number.
Is the grace a little ahead? Yeah, isn't there one over here?
I don't even know where I would get lobster from.
Oh, not this guy.
Like, how are you just listening to them?
That's so crazy.
Level design of Lindell is my favorite because everything's like just, you just really see the sheer scale of everything between that dragon.
And I don't even remember, but who's that dragon anyways? I forget.
I have to look that up.
It's just like, it's just crazy to me.
Like, who did that? Who did all that?
Yeah, that's right.
That's what I call it. Grants access bolt.
Like, one of my favorite things I've been learning about lately is like the crucible and like old, like pre or tree lands between.
And it's like, because Parthenax or Parthenax, I can't remember his name, was an Elden Lord.
But like, nobody knows like to whom he was the consort to yet.
And I thought that was super interesting because it's like talking about how you see like the Elden Ring.
You can see its wildness and the crucible was still very strong.
Yeah, no, I know I can get to that.
I got the frenzied flame ending.
Yeah, on the Glomai Queen.
The God skin. Yeah, like that's so interesting to me.
What was the thing?
Like, I like the fact that people always have the crucible was like, it's not like an actual tree that was consumed by the tree.
But then people are starting to realize that it's almost like a force.
And the crucible was a type of like force, like a different sort of energy, pre or tree, pre gold and order, all that stuff.
And it was kind of untamed and like just represented like all life.
Yeah, primordial energy. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Recently, I've been learning about the Outer Gods and how I kind of pictured them.
And I like because I watched this video by Smogetown.
Very good lore analysis channel, I highly recommend you check it out.
And they dive into because like I always thought the Outer Gods were like Eldritch beings like kind of like Outer entities that are similar to the greater well, maybe a little, a little smaller, but like also like just entities.
But when I was listening to this video, I talked about how they're again Japanese translations and stuff that it's more of Outer Gods because they're outside of the current order of things, the golden order, they're not part of this order.
So they're Outer Gods.
Another thing that I liked is the Japanese translation kind of sees them as their Kami and Kami is a God or like a spiritual representation of a thing, but not like a God God, like an old God.
That's more of like Dark Souls and stuff.
So it's like the God, Outer God of Ra is just like the spiritual just manifestation of Ra.
And it's not like an actual entity.
It's like all the forms of the Outer Gods are different forms of death because you have like the formless mother, which is blood and bleeding and dying that way.
And then you have the God of Ra, which is like decay.
And then you have like the death birds and the ghost flame and all that stuff.
And that's just kind of like death by that.
It's interesting how all the Outer Gods represent a form of death.
It's very interesting to me, but they're not physical entities, they're just energies.
It's just a spiritual representation of a thing of an existence.
It's really fascinating.
And then that all, and it all just comes down to like the greater will just cares about order, doesn't care about what order there is, what type of control there is, it's just order.
I'm self soothing with Elden Ring Lore right now.
Yes.
Well, that's just my opinion.
I just share this opinion with this YouTuber, this YouTuber that the Outer Gods are not actual Eldritch beings that are like gods that are fighting for control from the greater will.
They are just forces that also exist like the Crucible and are just all wanting their own control, you know?
Yes, and all of them seemingly came around the death was injury. Yeah, exactly.
The God probably for yes, because death was finally present. Exactly.
In America, I will talk a lot about America's lore when I get to the DLC.
Yeah, a lot of things came to be like, I love the concept of duality in this game and light and darkness, like, you know, Shadow of the Ertree, then you have like Radigan America of Micola and Satrina.
And it's like you attain the sort of Godhood you get split into and it's like, it's very reminiscent of the defined feminine and defined masculine.
And it just, because like my belief, because people like to argue that Radigan was his own separate entity before America and she like absorbed him.
I don't believe that. I believe that when America reached Godhood, it just split her into the highest form of herself, which is two beings that define feminine and the divine masculine.
Yeah. Yeah, the Frenzy Flame is chaos, chaotic death. That's the Outer God, the Outer God of the Frenzy Flame.
It's chaos, Outer God of Chaos.
Yeah, Decay and Rebirth is very prevalent and there's a lot of Christian parallels in Eldering that I actually really like too, to be honest with you.
Chaos equals death.
Well, it's just, it's unbridled. There's no control. It's just chaos. There's no order at all, technically. So it just leads to death.
Almost like unnecessary death.
Radigan America's Topa.
Yeah, they can separate themselves. Yeah, can separate themselves from St. Trina.
Before, like when I first played the game, I thought St. Trina, I always thought St. Trina was Micola, but he just like, it was his alter ego, not like they're actually two separate beings, which is very interesting to me.
Yeah, exactly. It's like, life is gone, life is, that is the ultimate form is just unbridled chaos and death.
Yeah, Trina deserved better. Trina just wanted the best for Micola.
I'm trying to come chat with Stacey.
But yeah, no, I love the creation stuff of like the lands between and the gods, like analyzing that in the cultural systems, because there's so many different cultural systems, like learning about like the deathbirds, how like before, like when death did come to be
Before the Erd Tree, like they had a job, it was their job to take care of death, and that is evident from the weapon that they carried, the item description, I forget the name of it.
Chaos, life is not, yeah, yes, not exactly. Yeah, okay, I totally agree.
But it's like, it's like life cannot be consistent almost, you know.
I didn't listen to the Dung Eater's lore yet, to be honest. I don't know a lot about that, but God, that like the Dung Eater follows.
The Formless Mother is very interesting to me, because when he does his attack, he reaches into her existence, her plane, to grab that flame and blood.
And it's everything, it's so interesting because like Al, there's like fire is represented, like you have the frenzied flame, you have the Formless Mother's like blood flame, you have the ghost flame, and it's all kind of ties back to this opposition of the Erd Tree.
And you realize why America is trying to suppress all other possibilities, because it's like a threat to her creation.
And honestly, like, I'm kind of happy, and hindsight, I picked the frenzied flame ending, because I don't want to be America's consort.
I want to destroy everything she created, because she did it terribly, she's a crappy God.
So is Mikula, the whole family sucks.
Yeah, no no zone.
But yeah, it's very, very interesting, but sorry. Sorry for the tangent, I was self soothing with Elden Ring Lore. I just love Elden Ring Lore so much.
Look, he's just listening. I don't want to interrupt.
Oh, they're having a good time.
Can I just dump down here? Yeah.
Isn't there doggies? Yes.
Can I hit you from here?
Nope, can you come close doggie?
No, okay, there's two doggies.
The cast time is very, very long, though.
I'll take whatever fricking bones you got. Oh, Beast Blood.
Elden Ring Lore video went? Oh, maybe. I wouldn't mind doing that.
I also really like the, I've already got their name. It's like the Tarnished Archaeologists, they like dive into all the cultural influences, like the historical influences, like physical archaeological finds and comparisons and how they have been incorporated into Elden Ring and like the different cultures and stuff, and that was really cool.
And there's also the character that's in like, Mawgwin Palace that people call like Elden John, which is funny, and they think that he was some sort of Elden Lord, but I don't think so.
I think he was actually a preacher, like a prophet that was prophesying, almost like a Jesus type character or like, no, not like Jesus.
What was the prophet? Which prophet? I'm trying to think of a specific prophet in the book, in the Bible, and I can't remember.
Who ever wrote the book of Revelation? And I feel like he was kind of, I think, was it Daniel? I don't remember.
And I feel like he's kind of the equivalent of telling people that the world as they knew it was ending.
That's my idea. He was pro-clear, because it shows in on the slab that he's holding, it's a tree, which people said like, oh, he could have been like something about the crucible or something.
And like, when we get to the DLC, I'll talk about the spirals and stuff and like the horn scent and their cultural ideals and stuff.
But like, I feel like it was the ur-tree on his tablet, and he was predicting the golden order.
This is going to take a while. I'm just going to run past these people. I'm so sorry. Oh yeah, you're not really doing anything.
Yippee! I'm terrified of heights and platforming.
Oh, like how y'all get triggered, like one at a time.
Oh, no, I really don't want you guys here. We can't really do this now, please. Oh, I'm going to get poisoned.
Okay, well, I'm going to let that go down.
Oh, come on, guys. Why aren't you diagrowing yet? Oh, come on. Oh, I didn't mean to do that. I wanted to do that.
Oh, frick. Oh, frack and fro. Oh, man. You know what? I'm going to use the mimic tier, because I'm not having a good time.
Go do something. Go do something about that, right now.
Oh, God. Although, I know he's not that bad, actually.
Oh, I wasn't paying attention to my health. That's awkward.
Yeah, I feel like they should have died more into Erlana's stuff.
Oh, well, am I? I think I'm like 132.
Oh, why could I see him for a second? That was weird.
I feel like this will be...
Hold on.
Hold on. No, stay stuck behind that pole. I got stuff over here to do.
Nope, pull out.
Go do something, mimic tier. Do something about that.
I don't want to be stuck in a corner.
Fight over here, please. No, you're already going to die.
You frick. I'm over here.
No, I was using you for bait. I nearly weren't touched.
Oh, that does blow damage, actually.
Oh.
Oh, please. I'm not ready to die.
Looks like I really didn't need to mimic tier.
Ow.
I'm not getting the timing right.
Oh, no.
Oh.
Nothing personal, kid.
I had to use the watch of a college.
The moon veil. I always like to feel like cheese with a bunch of spells and then I'll just...
And then I'll just do it with my weapon and feel like I did it without any help.
Okay, now to get the icon.
I'll bite a cake.
Celebratory cake, Grapple Me.
Celebratory cake.
This cake is so good.
Ooh, me. Why are you so adorable?
Yeah, where is that?
Wait, do I have to kill Godfrey for it?
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Okay, I'll fight.
Mm-hmm.
Yeah, she thought the fight was hilarious.
She was just like, yeah, no, give me the, give me the voids.
I'm gonna click that real quick and I'm like, it was members.
She's like, ah, frickin', goddammit.
And she's like, download and send it to me.
I'm like, okay, she's like, wait, never mind, I'll just get into your account and get it myself.
I'm like, okay.
She said I could write the script.
I begged her again.
She said fine.
She didn't say fine, like, oh my god, fine.
She was like, all right, I just don't want you getting stressed out.
So, I'm gonna do a theme based off of my Halloween outfit.
Maybe I'm a, oh, you never know.
Or maybe I'm a,
or maybe I'm a R, matey.
Where is the ever jail?
Where did you say it was?
Maybe I'm a, more, more, more, more, more, more, more, more.
Down the ravine.
Do you think I know what a ravine is?
You gotta say south, southeast.
Where's southeast?
Oh, okay, I'm gonna go around.
So I'm gonna go around, I am.
I'm a slime girl.
Okay, maybe I'm a slime girl, glub glub.
Maybe I changed my mind a lot.
I don't know what a slime is, visible in the map.
Oh, look at that, then.
You're so right, Haram, you're so right.
I'm not a fairy.
Why are you guys keep saying I'm a fairy?
I've never been, oh, snap hola, I've never been a fairy.
What's that?
It looks pretty, I want to pick it up.
It's art, art terrierly.
I can jump down, right?
Yeah, that's fine.
Oh yeah, we're good.
Oh yeah, we're fine, don't worry, that's it.
What do you mean, the wolf quest stream?
What was going on in the wolf quest stream?
It's funny that you have to unlock it.
Excuse me.
Is there a state of America nearby?
Wait, how much rooms do I have?
Okay, I understand, I was lost with you.
Tell me, okay, I have 102.
Alright, after I kill him, I will level.
Come on.
Oh, why did I, why am I doing this?
I didn't mean to press that.
Why am I like this?
Oh no, I already freaked this out.
Why is he in here?
Why am I suddenly not being able to know how to play?
Why is he so strong for no reason?
I actually just might let you kill me
because I just totally freaked stuff up.
Ow, ow.
Ow, you slammed my head against that.
I don't have any FP, oh no!
Yeah.
Walk, walk, walk, walk, walk.
Can I, can I get some, can I, can I please?
Thank you for letting me heal, I appreciate that.
Oh, I jumped too early.
I jumped too early.
I jumped too early on the rest.
Where's the bleed? Where's the bleed?
I jumped into that.
Oh no.
It's not that hard, I don't know why I'm struggling right now.
Wow.
Can I like breathe for a second?
Oh, get your little hands away from me.
I don't like that at all.
Where's my blood buildup? That's my question.
I'm gonna die.
Okay, I got cut room so I can move on.
Interesting.
God of Thru, God of Thru.
God of Thru, God of Rick, God of Thru.
God of Frick, God of Rye, God of Lick, God of Bi, God of Tick, God of Die.
In the Everdale, we gonna fly.
Yeah, I'm gonna.
I won't do what I did before.
Bye.
Oh.
Why do you do that?
I'm like kind of tired.
I'm gonna spam my thing and you're gonna spam your thing and it's just...
Oh, I said I'm gonna try to heal there.
What is happening?
I didn't think you were gonna be able to reach me, but you did.
Why can't...
I'm just not doing things fast enough for me to get repost or bleed.
Okay, I did get a little bit of lead there.
Oh, I'm gonna expect that.
What?
What's happening here?
I can never dodge that attack for some reason.
He's an airbender.
He got that Extendo range.
Go, go Gadgets.
Welly Whirl.
Welly Dirl.
That is it.
Okay, I feed Fia in like an hour.
Midra's cool.
I like Midra's design a lot.
I kind of want to listen to that lore again because I listen to the Frenzy Flame and Midra's lore,
but sometimes they just don't...
Like, I'll listen to it or read something or all this, but I don't really consume it.
I might have fallen asleep during that too.
Okay.
Yeah!
25!
Okay, I have 20 rooms.
Let me see.
Hmm.
Oh, I didn't mean to do that.
Always...
Nope.
I always...
Click the wrong things.
Midra was a fun fight.
Oh, I need a membership.
Okay.
Wow!
I...
Just not enough.
Why am I sitting?
I press the wrong buttons all the time.
It's been four hours.
Crying for the majority of it.
Well, I'm probably going to do this for like five, like nine hours, so...
Do I have more rooms?
Warming stone.
Okay, I won't...
Not gonna really...
I want to use up all of these,
and I'm gonna go upgrade stuff.
I also don't want the little ones just sitting.
I hate though that...
I just...
I wish it wouldn't...
I have to keep going into my inventory to do this.
Did I get the...
Okay, yeah, I did get that.
So I just couldn't remember if I got the Purifying Crystal tier.
Bye-bye!
Have a good night!
Thank you for stopping by.
I didn't mean to press that.
Let me get away from this thing.
She's singing the song over people.
She's not hungry.
She has food in her bowl.
Actually, I can't really tell from here.
I can't see over the edge of the bowl.
So they're actually...
Her food...
The food will go off in a little bit.
All right, whatever.
Oh, it's raining.
I like it when it rains with the game.
Eee, D. B. D. B. D.
All right, whatever.
Oh, it's raining.
I like to go into rain until the game.
Eee, D. B. D. B. D.
Oh, it's getting dark. They're not able to see, which nice and cold is this, which nice and cold is this big man.
No, she caught a ball, her ball. She likes to yell with her toy in her mouth.
Reyna, what did you get? Reyna, come here.
What did you catch? Come bring it over here.
I'm asking nicely.
Reyna, aren't you catching the food for me? Don't you want to feed me or kitten?
She's still meowing. No, Boomi's leaving because he's wondering what she has.
Yeah, it was her victory. So when Kat like still walk around with her toy, I'd be like, I killed this toy.
And I usually go over and I pretend to eat it. I'm like, oh my God, thank you. So good. You did such a good job, Reyna. Wow.
Wow, Reyna, you're so talented.
She's still meowing because I haven't gone to see her yet. My Boomi's going to see her. It's funny because then she'll just hiss at Boomi.
She's still yelling. Let me shut this off until he comes back.
Don't worry. I feel so bad that Mary could put you here, you poor little omen.
Oh, it is kind of important. You try to get something that kills a god.
I don't have an eight. Damn it.
Where does a somber stone eat?
I don't need a glove wart for you. I can go buy some glove wart, actually.
I wish like he offered something of value. Where the heck is he? I feel like I was supposed to do something. I don't really care.
I don't know why his room opens if I can't do anything.
Wait. Am I tripping?
Offer a bell. I don't have a bell, do I? Oh, I do.
I have any more? Okay. I didn't think I had anything to offer.
Thank you kindly. I don't know why you're like conjoined. Again, duality.
I forget what his name is. It's like Kasa or something.
Because I was just like, what is the point of him? He's just a silent dude that hangs out off near Arkidian, whatever.
ID. What's going on, D?
Nephaly quest line time. Why do I need to do Nephaly stuff? She's not even there.
And it's funny because I talked to her, so I don't know what happened with that.
Oh, wait. I didn't mean to talk to you. I meant to come over here.
Greetings, we have a spirit.
Gold beans.
We can say they assomber stony. What? They definitely don't.
I probably have to upgrade the shop in order to do that.
I bet it was like, offer them this frickin bell bearing and you can do that.
Ma'am? Yeah. What does this do?
Yeah, because I'd have to do that. The crystal caves.
Oh, hi, Reyna. I know, you're a boomy. Wait, what the heck?
You psyched me out. You tricked me. You tricked me.
I thought you were Reyna in the darkness.
Okay, I'm just wearing the carrion armor, but thank you.
Everybody gets the carrion armor early game for an int build.
But thank you for your suggestion. Don't worry about it.
Yeah, I would have to kill those two crystal ladies to get that,
which would be smart, to be honest, because then I could just go.
What I should have been doing is I should have been going and killing all the NPCs for the bell bearings.
So, carrion armor is always drippy.
Okay, I'm going to bonk some on the stick.
I feel like I can do some serious damage with those crystals on the end, to be honest.
The fact that there isn't like a crystal sword that looks like that is kind of crazy.
Boomy has been a good boy. Boomy's been my emotional support.
Oh, it's Emmy. Hi, Emmy. Hello. Hi, Pimp Pals. Hi, Raiders. What are you guys doing?
What's going on? What it is? What's up?
I got to go to Mount Gelmere for Sombra Age.
See, this is the thing about Ullinary. You just get like sidetracked.
And I'm like, oh, I got to do this next. Oh, I got to do that.
Hello, Ultrabee. Hello. Hello.
Welcome in, Pimp Pals. How was the stream?
Stream 10 out of 10, yeah? I hope so.
You're drawing my little pony.
Oh, my little pony.
I always wondered what friendship could be.
I don't say my little pony rules.
I would love to make a pony, Sona.
I would just obviously be like a little rope for my cutie mark.
I will say it once and I will say it again.
But then you shared all this magic with me, my little pony.
Oh, Oshimarks are just cutie marks for VTubers.
Hi, Pookie.
What OC did you make? Now, I'm curious.
Was it one based off of yourself or did you just make your own one?
Or make one for Dupin Pals?
Exactly, yeah. Agree with me.
Feed my ego. That's so true. That's so true, Queen. Speak your truth, Queen. You just made yourself
as a pony. Cute. I bet you would look like, um, similar to this scooter or like, there's like,
I think Applejack's little sister. One that's like with freckles, I think. I can't remember.
I haven't watched my little pony in a while. Yeah, a horrible little gremlin. You guys would just be
like a dilapidated, disheveled, spike looking thing. Like a dragon. Scootaloo. Yeah, I always
like Scootaloo's name. It's so cute. Oh, what the heck? Hi, hi guys for Lulu. Hi, hi guys for Lulu.
Thank you for your raid. Hello. How's it going? I think you're collabing with Emmy, weren't you?
That's cool. Or you're going to collab. I can't recall. I haven't looked at the schedule.
Hi, if you're new here, Raiders, my name is Shibi Cottonbum. I am your favorite girl failure dom.
I am part of Veilers Gen 1 Indulge. And that's my cat Raina singing the song of her people
because she is playing with her ball. But thank you for the double raid. I feel very loved.
What I'm doing, I'm dressed up as a nun right now because I'm Seiso. I'm a Shimi Seiso. I'm the
most pure, virginal, even VTuber. Yes. So, and we're just like kind of doing some quick thing,
not quick, it's taking forever because I am slow and I talk a lot. We're doing some things where
I'm just kind of grabbing a couple things before I go to the DLC. I still need to kill Mogue. I
feel like I've been like subconsciously putting it off and getting sidetracked by other things.
But we'll see. But yeah, if you want to stick around, stick around. If you don't,
that's fine. Get some rest, get some water, take a nap, go to bed.
What's that? The shark boy and lava girl song? Shut your eyes. Dream, dream, dream, dream.
Taylor Lautner killed that. Not going to lie. Not going to lie. Your recent Twitter posts
with 10 degrees are true without your holiness. I don't know what you say. I do not recall what you
speak of. I give advice. I give advice on life. On my advice on life, stop living. Yeah. Yeah.
That's the best thing you could do. That's the best thing you could do.
I'm kidding in Minecraft in Elden Ring because there's no death in Elden Ring, you know? Dream,
dream, dream, dream, dream, dream. Let me give you the cutie girl ranch. The cutie, cutie girl, cutie
mark ranch. Nifty. Shark boy and lava girl comedy. That was a drama. I don't know what you're talking
about. Far into the game. What are you? Um, so I can show you right now. Beep, beep, beep. Because
I've just been, um, I haven't been like doing, doing stuff. I've already beat this game before
on my PlayStation. Oh, I didn't mean to go there. Um, I was just farming recently to get levels up,
and then I just got Moog Shackle. And then I just, um, I forget what I just got, to be honest with you.
And now I'm debating whether or not to go kill the crystal ladies for their ball bearing in the
mines for the somber, but I think I might just kill Moog instead. I think I need to stop. Yeah,
I need to, I have the good offer. I also just feel like I need better things.
Oh, memory stones. Oh, there's eight and nine and Caleb. Yes. I think I, do I have nine?
Yeah, I have nine. I literally just need eight.
I think I have to go get eight now.
Oh my God. Why do I have, oh yeah, I have two of those. Why did I buy that then? I didn't know I
had three. I hate that I have to go in order. Why can't I just do the biggest one?
I might need some spell slots. You're probably right. But where else do I get memory stones?
All right, well, we're going back to Caleb, Caleb, Caleb. We're going back to Caleb. I don't think so.
Going back to, oh hi, Boomi. Hi, are you coming back for the kitty cam?
Sir? Oh, you're knocking stuff over. You're tripping. You're falling.
Boomi, you can't be on my desk unless you go in the bed. Lay down. Good boy. Good boy,
Boomi. Good boy. Now he can put in the kitty cam although it's dark. He's looking his butt,
so maybe I shouldn't be putting on the kitty cam. Why are you so gross?
I can't reach my light.
There we go.
The baby boy. Why are you so far away? Come closer. I want to see you.
Boomi is back.
Boomi. Good boy. Good boy. I'm not being mean. I'm praising him. He's stinky.
He likes his nose rubbed. Okay.
Where is that? I forget which thing it is. Maybe is that why I had this checked off?
Is that the cave that you get to the mines for that one?
Boomi don't need. Boomi's trying to hit the light switch. Can you not?
Boomi, the people want to see you. Come lay back down.
Good boy. Oh my gosh. What are you eating in there? Lay down. Thank you. Good boy.
Boomi.
Wendell Ash. You need the lifer in plus two. No.
Southwest of it. Oh, it says in Dragons Barrel. Over here.
Or this one. There's a lot of towers.
Oh, it's the falling Starbeast cave. Oh, Dragon Barrel has a memory stone. Where?
Southeast. Over here. And this thing.
Yeah. Okay. Stop.
I'll get the memory stone. It's always good to have more memory.
A little bit.
That's not the way.
Well, I'll just run past the dragon.
You should shave your boobus. So I'm going to save your hand.
Good night. Who knows? Who knows if I even get to mow? To be honest with you.
Since I just delay. I have to go shopping.
Pick it up. Not even worth it.
Perhaps. Maybe I lied. Oh, is this where the Knight Rider dude is?
Good night. I might actually kill him.
No high burps. So I can get his rooms.
Because I remember trying to cheese him a bunch over here. I can't even remember what the cheese was.
Yeah, he crossed a bridge. What are you not there now?
Yes. I think I let you like stand. I remember like jumping over the edge a bunch for some reason.
Yeah, you make them jump off the bridge. That's what it is. Did they patch that?
Or you lead them through here. I remember doing that. I'm just rocking over everything. It's fine.
Where is the entrance? I hate these little dudes. They just look like little monkeys.
I need a what?
Use that string string and open balcony to get into the tower. Oh.
Yeah, I remember trying to do poison build up on him with the boluses.
I never get you're not supposed to go down the path to avoid them.
I feel like there's more poison boluses.
Where are we going? Maybe I just want to go on an adventure. Did you ever think about that?
Maybe I just want to travel. Maybe I want to see the world.
Wait, why did I do that?
Okay.
Why do I get to the freaking thingy?
Let's go. Jumping.
It'd be funny if I died and I just didn't notice. I'm not gonna bother healing. Oh, you know what I could do?
I'm gonna break into this room. That's what I'm gonna do.
Got on a roof and slide down. Where's the what? To what balcony though? I can't see it. I made it.
What? Where's the balcony at? Is it that one? Over there?
What?
Bye-bye. Everybody going to bed.
Wow. To the building. To the walls.
That's right. I thought I saw it on this side. No? To this side? Yes. Goodbye torrent.
Wow. I'm breaking. Oh.
I noticed at the last second.
I literally said, oh, it'd be funny if I died because I'm not paying attention.
Oh, that's really good.
And then I literally saw the sliver of Halsa had left and then I tried to do it and then
Sheepy, why? Did I ever say it was good at video games? No. Why is myself up here instead of in the rise?
That's weird. All right. Anyways, so I started Blast. Hello. It's Boopy.
It would be a shame if somebody destroyed everything in this room. That'd be so terrible.
Such a travesty. How dare they, you know?
What the? What is that? I'm assuming this won't work on it. What?
All right. I'm kind of scared.
Oh, it's like a bunch of them. How am I supposed to kill this thing?
I need to do blood build. That's what I need to do.
I don't have any stamina. Let me go away first again.
Pardon me to drive these babies for miles.
Are you meant to like cheat your way in here like by doing that? Because I think I remember
I specifically went to get the thing. All right. I don't care about whatever it's attacking me with.
Wow. Oh, I like knocked it down.
Well, I'm not locked on.
I hate that. It's like an amalgamation of, oh, oh, oh my god, the hell?
Of all like the sorcerers, it's like really freaked up.
I didn't even have to kill you. There's nothing in here. Brother, what? I was wasting my time.
Maybe I just needed to kill that amalgamation. Okay.
Yeah, I know that happens to Selen. It's very depressing. I never finished Selen's quest.
I remember reading that.
That's me for the fun of it.
I need you to think of it.
Be by marching.
Oh, memories.
America, y'all America, y'all.
Oh, yeah. Where was the other place I have to go?
For the ball bearings?
Hello.
Honestly, I should go to Selen for glint stone sorceries.
I realized that when I was watching stuff that I should have gone to her and done her quest.
My bed.
That was cheesy as fuck. I mean, it's frick. Now you're gone.
Now you've been yeeted just because you're a terrible joke. I'm not mad. I'm disappointed.
You could have done better.
Which bell bearing? Ah, the one for the somber stones.
I forgot where the crystal girly pops are.
No, I'm going to kill, if I kill Mogue, will I still be able to do a quest? I'm assuming yes.
Oh my god, Reina. Oh my god, Reina. No, Reina. Reina.
Oh my god. Reina. Reina is climbing all over me.
Hi. I'm so proud of you for catching that ball, Reina. Wow.
My big mama still providing for me after all these years.
I'd show you her, but she's like on my shoulder right now.
She's purring. Let me get her some. I don't know if they'll be able to hear it over the room.
Okay, I just need, I just need the eighth stone. That's all I want.
Okay.
A cellulia crystal cave?
What? Tau? There's multiple Tau. Oh, this here, this Tau or that Tau? You got to be more specific.
I'm a dumb. I'm a dumb dumb.
The divine tower? The Esma?
What that? Is that where it is? Is that the S?
Is that it? The music just skipped there. Okay, Reina. I can't have you like that.
This one? You guys just got to give like the cardinal directions.
You're a patient? What does that mean? Oh, perishing.
Okay, I suppose we go then.
Ah, Reina just sat on my controller. Ah, okay, she just jumped down.
Oh, what should be the fastest? I don't have any graces up here because I never went up here.
Because I know there's like a race up there where you can fight the invader person.
Oh.
Sounds like there's always a swarm of bees.
It's funny that this wall doesn't hurt you. It always confused me a little bit.
I feel like the wall should be able to hurt you when you get too close.
Not the bees!
Oh yeah, I hate this divine tower because I remember falling off at it a bit,
a bunch. Getting knocked off from the ladders and stuff. Little perches.
Hi, I know you like this, whatever it is.
I'm coming for you. Yeah.
Oh.
Hi. Hi, welcome to Applebees. Would you like the apples or bees?
We're actually out of apples, so all we have is bees. Would you like the bees?
The bees need them.
I literally saw you like 15 minutes ago. I got a pee. I got a pee.
Yep, I could actually level this up too. I swear I have four.
Wait, what do I need for that actually? I wasn't paying attention. Maybe I'm thinking
of a smithing stone for. I could have sworn I have a three. It doesn't matter. I can just go to
EG for that. Oh, Lord Beesbury, Beesbury, Mac and Bees. He has selected the bees,
released the bees, and the whole place just like goes insane because somebody ordered bees.
I feel like do I have a four?
Thought I had a four, I guess I don't. I know I don't have a five. I know I have a five, six,
I have a six and a seven.
I don't know why I did that.
I had a four. I said I didn't have any stored. Oh wait, stored, whatever.
Next time, this time I'll make you fire for that. What do you mean? I already fought for my life.
Do you want me to die again? Because of ice cream, my lactose and taller pants?
I almost died. I almost, I almost was not long for this earth.
Who's the nun? None of your business, so long as I have lactate. I just didn't eat it.
Yeah.
No, don't die pretty late. You're so hot. Don't die.
I like that meme of where like there's like, they replace the sword with the player model
T posing and he's just smacking the Bible. He's just smacking it.
What? What's the matter? Don't look at me like that. What do you mean? Stop it.
There's a quick port. Well, I like to do the long way, which is go all the way to the bottom corner.
Reach out and touch grace.
Roderico, why are you making weird noises in my ear?
This is a good up. Just look it up. Google it. Just Google it. I feel like I should pee before this
battle. See, it's Eldon John, but I believe it is. He wasn't an Eldon Lord, I believe he was.
I bet he was part of a prophet, but it's so interesting like why are they worshiping him then,
you know? Why are you? Why are you?
I'm confused. Ow, I'm going to die.
How could this happen? Wait, where do I go? Wait, how do I get to Mogue again?
Torret, come down here right now. Yeah, elevator, because I'm like, wait, hold on,
let me get my runey poons, my poon, my poom poom. Actually, I might kill all of them just to get the runes.
Oh, no, no, no. Oh, I forgot there's a chest over here. Hold on, just a moment. I'll be with you momentarily.
That doesn't really do much. What about... ow, ow.
Ow. Ow. Oh, what's this?
Sweet. Wait, I really just actually already have the runes.
Oh, get down from there. Ow. Why am I not? Oh, I'm pressing the wrong button, that's why.
No, I'm out.
Now I'm going to kill you because I'm angry.
Guys are abominations to nature.
Oh, I'm out of FP. I'm out of puh. I'm out of puh puh.
I don't know I'm doing that, but, you know, oh, that doesn't work. I almost fell off this cliff.
Ow, that would have been awkward.
Yeah, get over here. I'm going to knock you off. Yeah. Oh, I'm going to die. Wait, wait, wait, wait.
I don't know.
I'm here to kill you. Why are you guys being so aggressive?
Okay, hold on. I'm just going to get my runes. Just going to get them.
You killed Lenny.
Oi. We got to kill Homelander.
Okay, I hear somebody next to me. I think I'm fine.
No, I'm not. No, I'm not. I'm not fine at all. I'm just going to leave.
Oh, why are you chasing? Oh, I almost jumped off the cliff. No.
Is that bully, Billy Butcher?
No, the healing is lava.
What is he going to do? Oh, yeah.
Yippee.
I don't think this is going to be enough.
No, I will have to kill them. I'll have to end them.
I must do what I must.
Bumi, what are you looking at? You're staring at the door and it's freaking me out.
Time to stand. Shut up, Alpha Watch. I don't need to stand. I won't stand.
I can't stand. You're asking me to stand.
Stand. I actually need to change my physics while I'm at it.
Um, I'm going to do the magic shrouding and do it to the purified crystal.
I wish you could have more than like, if you could have three for the physics, that'd be sick.
Um, blood for the blood god.
I'm just going to try to aggro one of you because I think that's all I need.
Oh, oh, you have a shield up. That's why.
He's going to creep towards me. Do they have silver tier shields? I just realized. Oh, no, they don't.
Oh, no, not the freaking.
Oh, oh, there you go.
It's not enough. How much do I need? I need 16k more.
I'm just going to aggro one at a time. Oh, uh, I don't think that aggro them one at a time.
I'd like to think it didn't aggro them one at a time.
I'm too far away. Oh, no, I'm not. Oh, I should be able to kill you.
Good stuff. Okay, thank you. Much appreciate.
Uh, no, I didn't have any rooms left. That's why I wanted to heal. Damn.
What?
Am I tripping? I thought it said 120. How many rooms do I have?
Oh, I apparently went to Sexic for a moment. I thought it said 121.
Hey, come back here. You. I'm going to aggro you.
How do I just aggro you? No, not you. No, not you.
Oh, oh, God. Oh, oh, uh, hold on. Let me just
just hold on just a moment.
Oh, you're going to kill me. Oh, blood build up. No, that's fine. I died close to.
Oh, they're like, yeah, you got him, boss. You got him.
Is the movie a plus 10? No, it did. I don't have an ancient dragon stone.
Perhaps a different approach. I prefer this approach. I think this is a good approach.
Yeah, come around town, brother. Come on around the corner, brother. Oh, never mind. You can jump.
This is awkward as hell. Well, well, that was a cool little spin you did. I'm just going to
spam my RB. Oh, you just totally freaking destroyed me. I didn't think I could be repost.
That was pretty bad ass, though, brother, to be honest with you. I'll be like real,
real, real true to you right now. I respect you for that. I respect you.
A hardcore for what you just did there. It was very impressive. I don't think that I've ever
seen anybody do it like you can. And I bet your mama is real proud of you because a lot of people
wouldn't be able to do that to me and you were able to do that to me. And so I think you're pretty
neat, I suppose. But I'm going to have to kill you. I'm really sorry. I hope I hope you don't
really take it as like a misunderstanding. But I am going to have to end your life. So if you can
hop over the wall, eat this, eat that, get stun locked, that would be, oh, you just parried me
and you're going to kill me again. I respect you for that. And I just can't believe that
happened twice, to be honest. I didn't know that he could parry. And I'm kind of disappointed
that MPC can parry me perfectly each time. I don't think that's really fair. I think that's a broken
game mechanic. I think FromSoft should fix their games because that's just disrespectful. I shouldn't
be having to fight against the AI, the AI are taking over and they're selling all of our data to
other countries. And I just don't think that's real nice of them. And the fact that they're using the
same AI and FromSoft games is just kind of sad. And I'm going to be out of FP in a moment, but
that's all right. I don't need FP where we're going. He just threw a knife at me and I'm going to stab
him, but he's probably going to parry me. Nope, he couldn't parry me. It's fine. That's real cool.
I'm happy we could talk. And I'm happy we could have this conversation. And I literally just ended
up with no FP. Sorry, FP. I apologize for making that mistake. I meant to say FP. I really got a
pay pay. That's for sure. I'm going to level up now. I'm going to put it into Vigor because I
definitely need more Vigor because I need to, I want to be at least like I like 60. I don't know
how many runes that a mogwin is going to give me, but that's fine. It's co or what the shibbity. I'm
going to go down this elevator and we're going to see what happens next. Okay, wait, I got a pay first.
I really think I should pay first. Should I pay first or should I, should I try to fight him while
holding my pay? I'm not quite sure. I don't know if it'll be distracting.
It has a somber for the weight. Does it have the agent dragon stone?
What? Hold on a moment. Hold on a moment there.
Oh, it do. I'm going to get out here real quick. It was real nice hanging out with y'all. Thank you
for getting me what I needed. I'm going to go sit down at this grace. I totally forgot that that
was in there. I'm going to go to the round table real quick. I can't do it because I'm aggroed
right now, but I'm going to sit down and de-aggro y'all. So it's been really nice.
Let me just pop on over. I think the moon veil was a great choice to be honest with you. So thank
you y'all for recommending me that. I really got to, you want me to, of course, of course,
the pin pals is a piss on him. I don't know if that would be effective. Well, we could try it.
Uh, I could try spraying all over him. I never knew. I don't know. Maybe it's acidic enough.
Maybe my pH balance is high enough that I could kill him with my, with my acidic pee.
Very spicy.
Wow. We did it y'all. We did it. Yeah. I see mo. We did it.
We killed the dude and when we got the dragon stone, we did it. We did it. We did it. Yeah.
Well, don't you think water, uh, debatable.
DLC is a cooler moon veil, but yeah, I want, but I wanted to go into the DLC with a cool weapon.
You know, I look kind of, I look pretty cool right now. If I do say so myself,
look at this, look at this pose. Ready? Boom. How's that make you feel? You're staring at greatness
right there. I saw I'm going to say you're staring at greatness. You're looking at the future.
You're looking at a future US military soldier right here. That's all I'm saying.
You're looking at a future military golden order soldier America and right again.
So you better put some respect on my name to be honest with you.
And you know what? This is America's ass.
What'd you say? You're trying to, you're trying to step up? Nah.
Oh, that's my cat food going off. I got to feed my cat.
I'm a goddamn marine. Okay, let me feed Fia. It's going to take me a little bit longer to feed Fia
because she's very weak right now. So I literally have to like spoon feed her stuff and down her
mouth because she it's hard. She can't really lick that well or swole while she can swallow but
she can't really like chew anything. So I literally have like I took a little plastic bag. I cut a
hole in one of the edges so I could like pipe pipe at like food into her mouth.
I was going to turn it but I'll talk and stuff so you guys can
See y'all. Hi, Miam. You look so cozy in bed right now. I'm going to ruin that.
I don't think I'm going to do it.
You might hear Fia speak because she doesn't want to be moved but she's not in pain or anything.
Oh, let's see. I need to give you your medication.
Okay?
Oh, da-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la-la.
Be good for jowls.
Because sometimes, if you make a little mess,
because I miss his or my,
I'm actually gonna follow you after you know, do that.
for you baby yeah thank you I appreciate you guys yeah it's pretty tough because I I've
never had to feed her by hand before but the doctor said this is the weakest
um she's ever seen her don't know why but you know I will do whatever it takes to keep
her going because she's not really motivated to eat right now because it's very hard for her to
I don't blame her that she's so tired that I can't eat anything
so what I do I trick her and so I took a little churu thing and I pipe it full of
her food and she thinks she's eating a churu because she refuses to eat otherwise I don't know
why it's very funny that's why I ordered more churus because I realize it's easier for her
not that I just can't I can't feed her off a churus but it does motivate her to eat a little bit
bitch gotcha don't even know what happened to you don't even know what happened to you did
you see coming put some more strength on my navel
the facts are like swarming me like vultures when we're trying to get the wet food
you
I
want to accidentally give her like
I don't actually get via free freeze because it's it was in the fridge and literally have
a plastic bag
you
but I'm glad I found a way to eat her because I was like
I can't do that.
I'm just moving your head so you don't have to wash your face.
I'm just going to have to wash my face.
All right, ladies.
I don't know.
I don't know. I don't know.
This is also the way to get her liquid because I was having to try to use a syringe to get liquid into her mouth.
It's actually difficult, so I just mix a lot of wet food with a lot of water until she's getting her liquid and she's getting her food.
It's very effective.
Even though I just don't like it.
That's good.
Good job, P.S.
I'm sorry.
I know it's uncomfortable.
But if she doesn't improve tomorrow with her eating and her strength, she still can't eat by herself.
I'm going to go over here to the hospital again.
Just to get a checkup.
Because it lets us know at a good time, you know.
But this is a very effective way of feeding her.
Yeah, we can have a walk over this one.
I got my hands full of fish.
I'm going to wash my hands.
Good.
Okay, you're going to hear Fia squeak because I'm going to lift her up.
And I'm going to see if I can get her to use the bathroom because she hasn't used the bathroom all day.
Come on, baby.
I know you're totally over me right now.
Hey, now I'll see you on your face.
Yeah.
No.
Yeah, I know.
Just like in the face.
And then I'm going to put you in the litter box.
Okay, I'm going to put you in the litter box.
And you're going to just rest right here.
And then you can try to go and I'll leave you there for a little bit.
You can't posture anything.
So I literally just have to put her in the litter box and like proper upright as well as I can.
And then hopefully she goes.
Sometimes she does, sometimes she doesn't.
I know you can hear her go, no.
Yeah.
Honestly, well, I know Fia's uncomfortable because she's not usually a talkative cat.
She only talks if she doesn't want something.
Although no, she actually she'll get really excited when she plays with her toys and she'll like start like yelling, which is funny.
Just like rain it is.
It's such a good moment.
Oh, thank you.
I try.
Because like what really makes me sad is that cats with her condition usually get put down because people don't understand that it can be like put in remission and stuff.
So I'm just trying to give her a good shot at life.
You know, she's like wiggling.
She's like, I just feel bad because she can't lift up her head right now.
Okay.
I've tried to express her bladder before myself, but it's pretty hard.
She gets usually pretty loud if I try to do it.
Yeah, she's my she's my little girl.
She's only a baby.
She's just a little baby.
She's a little kitten.
Rain is coming over all concerned.
I'm going to try to wash off the bed while you were in there.
And I apologize if the stuff was like depressing or something, but I'm just kind of explaining my process and just not like she will get better.
It just takes a long time.
Like I might take like two or three weeks for her to completely recover.
So don't think like she's just like stuff like this forever.
She's not.
I've been through this before with her.
It took her like a month to get better and she's tough.
And it's like a it's like rounds of steroids and other stuff.
And then usually she'll do okay.
Yeah.
I washed her back the best I could, but it's a very fuzzy bed.
So it's been a great movie.
You can share it with some friends or something like that.
I'm not sure how to try that with.
Be good.
Did you go?
I think with this condition, it's not like she can't pee.
It's like you can't posture.
And when a cat can't posture and they use a bathroom, they'll sometimes hold it, which can cause an infection, which is why I also I also give her like an antibiotic.
I'm going to get like a UTI, a little water infection.
Make sure I'm going to have to give her that right now.
I forgot to give her that medication antibiotic.
I'll do that after she gets a lot of water blocks.
I'm going to put her just in my little big bunniness that you guys saw me put together.
I sleep with her in that.
Something we just did with my father.
I pop her up usually super like in a bed with me in there.
She's just enough to roll around.
Hi Bea.
Are you done?
Did you go?
I didn't go.
I need to try.
Yeah.
I need to try to do it.
I don't want to go with her.
She took a bun.
She took a bun. She took a bun.
Oh, you're so good.
She took a bun.
You can't do this with your right hand.
The angle of that hand.
All right.
She's sleeping right after you guys.
But there you go.
You can chill a little.
I'm going to grab your pillow real quick.
Usually I would give her a treat every time she takes her pillow.
But because she can't chew, she doesn't want to strengthen her jaw.
I need to give her a treat and stuff.
Hello.
Hi.
Oh, you're so good.
You're so good.
I can't leave you alone.
Okay, now I have to pee.
I love to pee with some pets.
Yeah, she snuggled up right next to you.
She's actually laying using your head.
I mean, using your foot as a pillow for her head.
So she's chilling right with the harem.
And a little funny nest.
Very cozy.
I would need to create cats this week.
I just, it's the bare minimum.
To be honest with you.
It's like animals can't really defend themselves.
Or take care of themselves.
So, you know, humans got to step up and do the right thing.
I usually like will leave Fia for like 10 minutes.
And I'll come back and be like, are you mad at me?
She'll give me a little hand lick.
And I'm like, okay, we're good.
All right.
I'm going to use the bathroom.
Okay.
Alright.
Yes, I washed my hands.
Let me switch the lights.
Sometimes it's too bright.
Actually I'll keep the light off, my tracking is still fine, I might be a little bit belated
but I have an iPhone, it's supposed to be able to track me in the dark, aww, aww it's
Freddy!
Hi Sheebie, it's me, Funtime Freddy, welcome back for more Elden Ring, Triggery!
Well thank you for waiting, what was I going to say, oh yeah one of my goals is to have
a charity stream at some point for cats with her condition but also like dogs get it too,
dogs more often than cats and people can get it so it's called, let me pull up the, it's
called Myasthenia Gravis, is a chronic autoimmune disease that causes weakness in the body's
voluntary muscles which antibodies destroy the communication between nerves and muscles
resulting in weakness of the skeletal muscles and it's funny because like I also have an
autoimmune disease and I have fibromyalgia and so when they told me that she has this
I'm like oh my stuff just tells me that I'm in pain all the time so I'm just, it's kind
of funny that we ended up together but yeah no I would love to do that because yeah people
have it cats and dogs get it so I would love to do a charity stream for that at some point
because it's very hard to treat the disease besides with like steroids and hopefully like
trying to get the antibodies to do the right thing but I'm glad you guys agree with that
I completely understand your love for, yeah no yeah like they're all I have like I've only ever
grown up with like cats and dogs I'm an only child so besides you know my giant cotton
bin family but you guys know what I mean so I've always been very close with animals and stuff
always cool I remember when I was younger my, my nana she was cleaning the pool because my
grandparents on my mom's side had a pool and she was she had taken off the tarp it was like
right after fall they're opening up the pool and there was like some frogs in there so she
tossed them out but there's also like a chipmunk in there swimming around so she took it and like
chucked it out of there and I like I think I was probably like 11 years old I um I took off my
sweatshirt I scolded my grandmother at the age of 12 I'm like why did you do you could have killed
it and um this picture's a fee on my alt account and um so I took so my grandmother chucks this
chipmunk out of the pool it like almost like hits against the fence that's in the backyard I run
over I take off my little sweatshirt my little hoodie and I wrap my um hoodie around the chipmunk
and I pick it up and I um I bring it all the way to like the sunlight and stuff and I try
warming it up and I like I didn't give it mouth to mouth but I did like little chest compressions
because when I was younger I wanted to be a veterinarian um it was very much like my dream
to be a veterinarian when I was younger and so I was able to resuscitate the uh the chipmunk
and then uh I remember bringing it and I was holding it because I could see it was awake and
stuff I brought it over to like the edge um of my grandparents property that's like kind of the
other forest and I put it down on the ground and it like kind of like blinked and looked at me
like a thank you and then it ran off it was great and then since that day I was like I'm
gonna save lives but I didn't become a veterinarian because then I realized how refreshing it was
yeah they gotta do some stats for another reason um yeah my mom was very sad on me being a vet uh
she like wanted me to go to a like a vocational school for it um but I I lied to her when I said
this is like when I was this is like a high school vocational school um
and I turned I said to applied because I was just very self destructive I was just like I don't
deserve a veterinarian so yeah it's a tough job it's a very tough job um just the conversations I
have like with my vet like I would just cry the entire time if I was a vet like seriously I have
too empathetic for that um okay so let's go to Moog far across the distance in spaces between us
oh thank you guys thank you I appreciate it
everybody deserves a little kindness from the smallest animals to accept mosquitoes because
I destroyed that mosquito um to to humans to the biggest biggest things oh I thought I was going down
for a second um I'm gonna try to I'm actually honestly terrified because this is the point
where I beat Moog and then I gotta do the DLC and I'm honestly so scared because I know everything
about the base game and I know nothing about DLC except for the lore and I'm so anxious to cross
that into the unknown into the unknown and centipedes and ticks I actually I don't mind
centipedes I don't like house centipedes they they're the things that look like uh the Celia
crystal cave things um can I I didn't mean to do that I meant to do the flask but that's fine
probably should have done it when he appeared but it's cool doesn't matter
Moog deserved better Micola is a gaslighter and tricks people oh it's so creepy though
reach out touch babe it's weird that's like Micola's arm because like he's supposed to be like
an immortal child well like forever cursed to be a child um but he's like in the egg he's kind of
like normal sized I just like the song centipede by knife party I love knife party
centipede
I'm so sorry that you were hypnotized against your will to be in love with him so that he
would poison your you would poison his blood just so he could go to the shadow lands
it's so funny his voice doesn't match the character to me
and Moog has such an interesting face compared to like market
he sounds so sweet when he talks to Micola and then he sounds like a dick um
otherwise uh I realize I probably should have
uh oh
I forget his moveset already what's how does this work
hmm oh where's my sword hello whoa what's happening here
whoa I'm like scared to get close
although he has like the same moveset as all the oh get out the way get out the way
twist
I hear somebody throwing up in the background who is it
what's happening I kind of want to die so I can see
how am I still alive how am I still alive how am I still alive
okay I couldn't I don't know why is something feeling what are you doing
who's throwing up oh why are you just making a lot of noise
boomie are you just
boomie's just eating so fast he's gagging bro packs are so much sometimes where's Raina
there is
ma'am I'm going to need you to show yourself there's a 50 places you hide in the apartment
there
uh yeah I'm pretty sure it was just boomie just like sometimes boomie eats so fast she
gags like a dog does um she was sitting so I had like these little cubes that I put my
towels in I storm in on top of a shelf and so sometimes I can't find her I realized she just
goes into the cube like the little shelf thing a cube like it's a little like a soft um holder
for I don't know storage container and she just lays in there and I'm like great gotta rewash
these towels because they're covered in cat hair yeah boomies and that's what I was hearing I'm
gonna keep one headphone off because like I'm like getting tricked my mother instincts kick in
okay I think yeah with uh with the mimic I kind of I don't want to try a couple times without the
mimic because again I beat so many the bosses like I just like literally maxed out the black knife
and I maxed out my mimic and I was just like yeah and I'll just cheese and I'll just let the thing
wear it down and get propped and all that stuff and I'm just like no you know what this time I'm
gonna actually like get good you know it seems like the comet is effective
oh it's so slow
how about this
oh I didn't think that would hit me
oh I ran into that
oh my god I'm getting the timing all wrong it's fine
just being a boy just eating too fast
blasting smashing I like how sometimes I can see through this
all right let's do this thing to that thing up money make it roll wait what am I doing
and you stop pop lock it drop it wow that didn't do much
I don't want to be over here
okay this is better all right come on down
oh never mind
oh I forgot that explodes
oh
you have like a lot of range and it really varies sometimes I don't get that
I am forgetting that he'll attack me
it's funny because he's very weak to bleed so I really should just focus on that
oops
oops I'm trying to back up
oh back up back up back up back up back up back up back up back up
okay
oh no
oh they always do it right when you're peeling oh my god
it's okay it's okay I can beat yeah this is be fine I could easy get him to second phase
second phase might be a little bit more annoying but you know hi boomie
do you want to lay in the bed mister come over here come on the bed come on the bed
thank you big boy thank you
oh you plopped outside of the bed he literally just fell out oh boomie are you good you're walking
a little drunk there bud come back no all right he he got embarrassed because he sat in the
bed and he fell out of it I wish I caught that on camera yeah always yeah mocha is like really
insane range range range let me lean back a little bit let me get comfy
ow sorry just smack on my
I can definitely beat him without the mimic it's I can definitely do that
I wish I was like the type of person that's like good at games
like I wish I was like that sort of like crazy
like I was like I've always like liked games a lot um
but I've never and I'll like take have a special interest in stuff
I need to focus on oh wait I know what to do um
I really should have the uchi katana with me I want to think of it
will you like take a moment for me to change this to the uchi katana
oh okay never mind
wait let me
I like to play I played a lot of halo reach at halo reach is my favorite of the halo games
I used to play a lot of FPS's like I'll like I'll like no life stuff oh boomie are you back
are you coming to snuggle you look like you want to snuggle you come in to snuggle big man
you never want to snuggle you're giving me those eyes like you want to snuggle
what's up you want pets
are you gonna get into beds
get cozy boom come on mr boomerton you can't stand in front of my screen
with your booty in my face I don't want it okay mr pouch I'm gonna stick you into bed
there you go
again he is a scaredy cat
um and like I was I love like I used to really love FPS's uh I was decent at overwatch
I was decent at valorant I hated apex um I think the only game I was probably good at when it was like
free all the stupid stuff um it's probably destiny I think I was pretty good at destiny
but I like that I was like good I wasn't like cracked like I'm not cracked at games
I usually just get I'm just like decent you know yeah halo odst is also really good yeah I agree
um let me find another blood related item
can I use that no I can't
I really need string oh arcane that's what it was uh what do I need for this arcane why
does everything need arcane dumb I can't even use a torch can't even use a torch pull
I don't have enough strength for the torch pull can I wait for it oh actually no I can use this
uh let's try it
because this is blood loss buildup 50 and then how much is that for yeah okay we'll try it
tf2 I never played tf2 I liked I like I played instead of tf2 I played gary's mod a lot like I
was like prop hunt uh ttt again I want to get a game together or I can play that with the girls
I think that would be super fun
oh
I can't why are you backing up I can't hit you
I should jump forward
so
for him you need to be close to him
I'm just back up I'm like not ready right now
I'm
too I'm timing things I'm like literally a second early
bro just kill me just kill me just kill me thank you
pocket sands
I never played a monster hunter
most of 15 because I know like that would be so fun but the thing is like I don't think people
would play ttt like I don't think they would because of the name that's why I would probably try to do a
prop hunt you know people can be like sensitive and stuff
so
I can do this without the mimic here
oh no
oh
no I was too late that time
what are you doing
oh oh my god I'm so close to death
oh
yeah like I very much like I remember when I was younger I literally wanted to be a
professional csgo player oh hi boomi oh are you coming to snog what's happening
oh uh I can't fight right now boomi has come to snuggle he's on my folder this never happens
oh
this now he's with the boomerster
this is worth it
oh
his voice goes high like sweetly when he talks about michael it's funny oh hi boomi
you're switching shoulders
man there's no respect for puzzle
there's no respect for knights oh my god he's purring boomi why are you so sweet today
he's like the knight's my strength because I'm worried about your sister
oh he's really he gives like small rumbles he has it like uh purred really hard since he was a
kitten that's why I missed his he's made the he did the loudest kitten purrs but now he's too cool
for that but I'm getting a little rumble yeah I feel like I'm just a crazy
cat lady and all I do is talk about my cats I'm so sorry
very very drop sweet boomi
I don't know why the purrs stop at least you're just hanging out it's fine
the only time boomi wants to be held is when I come out of the shower which I don't really
understand why that is
no I need to brush you you're very
like he just insists insist to be picked up when I come out of the shower
like I'll walk towards the sink to like start to like brush my teeth or something
after I shower and he'll just come up and put his paws on my shoulder and ask to be picked up
and he'll make a beat a little purr and so I'll hold him for like a minute and then I put him
down and then he's satisfied I don't know why that's his routine
why do you look like you're crying are you okay are you feeling emotional boomi
yeah I think it's that like I definitely think it's like a smell thing
because boomi likes laying on like my clothes and stuff but he won't lay on me
so
that's why he's letting me hold him for this long
boomi is a sundae right
because he guesses of these uh no boomi usually like um
he likes to like stretch on me like he'll like reach his little hands up as if he wants
upies but he'll just stretch on my leg and then sometimes he forgets that even when I'm wearing
pants he can't use his claws oh my gosh boomi I need to brush you you don't shed this much
and I have cat hair all over my face and it's tickling me it's so worth
it
just the mom was but he is a mama's boy
he's a mama's boy
he like really likes my mom
anytime my mom comes over like boomi like loves my mom
and I've never seen him get so excited for anybody else besides my mom
so
boomi are you realizing it's a good thing to be held is this is what's happening right now
I'm gonna put you in the bed though my arms are hurting because you're heavy
and I'm going to brush you because you're literally covered in cat hair
okay
okay here I'll put on the webcam so you guys can see the brush and also
there's a big glove on the side of my desk
oh
you
I'm sorry I'm going to mess up your uh your thing
okay can we flip to the other side for me sir so I can put the other side
okay
he like went to buy it then like I slowly opened his mouth and closed it
hold up
here's something
look at that
you see this
I should sell this you guys want this put it in like a fan mail thing don't
have on reward I mail you boomi's birth
okay I'm gonna go check on fia because boomi keeps looking over towards her so I just want
to make sure she's good because boomi and fia are very bonded
okay
you
she gave me a little kiss she gave me a little kiss on my hand
always right in the world
okay I want to beat mok and then I guess next stream will be the DLC
because we're flipping it
I like how I have gideon in the thumbnail um I'm not gonna fight gideon at all
gideon no what's his name am I trippin his name gideon no it's not godfrey
okay
she'll become elden lord
I didn't make my thumbnails my manager does
okay I am so determined to do this
I usually switch between my items really slowly too I'm not super fast with it
because I have to take my thumb off the stick which I hate
what
oh okay
oh my god
oh he he takes like three seconds to actually do something I need to stop doing it preemptively
did we get a boomi head butt oh boomi just left what the heck I didn't even know she left
yeah boomi where'd you go oh he went to go eat food he went to go munch
I have to like claw it I don't know how people do that
I don't know why I did that because I make a difference
come back here
oh
Oh
Oh my god, why am I doing so bad like I was actually doing better in the beginning
Yeah, I know he's literally a Margaret. That's why I'm like what the heck
Cuz the thing where he like tosses the blood
Is literally like when heat Margaret throws the swords
Oh
Damn that was cold
Yeah, he's not bad thank you for it's gonna be great when I get past
The 15 mark and I just start to feel bad about myself because you said that thank you
Okay
Stare him down
Oh
That was a waste of a flask
I need to be behind him that's literally a
Cuz it's so funny cuz you'll walk like I watched somebody play against him like 50 times and I'm still like trash
Although obviously it's different from you like doing the controllers yourself
But like I don't know it's just weird like I felt so confident going into this
Why is my eye twitching
We guys sometimes get stuck in an animation
It's too late for that
Too early for that
He goes
One two
Something he's doing one two, but it's one two
One two three. It's it's literally three seconds. Hi boomie
Are you gonna go to the end of it again? Come on get into bed
Get into bed. Don't be scared of the Tupperware
Get in the best because I have the cake Tupperware
Get into bed
Yeah, that's what I'm talking about that's what I'm talking about cat time
Here
I'm trying to find a bright website so you guys can see it. I'm just gonna put Twitter on light mode
I
Don't even put Twitter on light mode. I don't even know on desktop
Maybe that's a good thing I don't know oh my god, boomie. You're so cute right now. What's up with your face?
Oh
There you go
Kind of helps brighten although you can only see boomies boomie booty I
Am kind of flash painting banging myself, but it's helpful cuz the so that for the tracking as well
All right, come on she be
It has been six hours
We've gotten kind of nowhere just get the show in the road shall we
Again too early
Too late
Oh
Why does it always get me
I
Think time flies when you're having fun six people are ours couldn't hurt
Maybe if I two-handed let's just do that I think I'm getting distracted by the flail
Oh
He's honestly very forgiving
You watch my game is me getting my butt kicked make you feel better
Is this why you guys watch me when I'm like this and I'm playing Elden Rings
It's the only time that my butt will be kicked
But talk he's a coolie
He has crazy reach
Really
Why is I don't I think I'm so used to like
Godric
That I'm thinking the timing of him because he's like one extra second
Or like millisecond and I'm still jumping before it
I
Didn't press B. I'm stuck. He really has me like sunlocked
Am I just not I like literally I'm frustrated because I didn't want to get the timing right
It's a dark cat camp. Yeah, there's really no point anymore having the cat camp up
Sorry, boo me your time is done
Give you a pet
Nicholas mine
Oh
Poop just you for good luck. Oh, my game just lagged. What was up with that?
I was like, why is it showing that I can wield it now that is not the case
I
That's not what I want to do why can't I what am I doing?
Thank you Jesus Christ
I
Scratch my nose
Like I feel like the hip-hop so I'm like really in what the frick
I don't even know you killed me already when I'm in that close if she shouldn't be able to hit me with the staff
I
Can't do dual swords. I don't have a blood build-up sword
I would have to use the flail and I tried that but it was just wasn't really working
I
Thought that wouldn't hit me
Again
I thought I could jump out of that. I guess not me back up
What I actually timed that probably like a millisecond off
I
Like I'm trying to like strafe him and I can't I don't know what's up with that
I don't like I'm trying to move behind I
Didn't think you'd go on a third time
I
Why do you back up so fast
I don't know why I didn't get into a second phase
More these
Yeah, maybe I need to I'm gonna try to do know something like I don't know why I feel like I'll be like cheatsy doodling I
Want to try my bestest I
Want to see if I can get I'm like super close
If for the next few attempts I can't get him to his second phase and I'm just gonna
No, you know what I forgot to come on. I already fucked this up
Oh my god, oh my god, I'm literally already gonna die
Oh, how did that not hit me? That's a great question. I
Thought I thought I know I didn't dodge that one
Oh
Me so give me your strength when we're 10 I'm doing so bad
I'm being disheartened
He's like stretched his neck out like he's a god-skinned Apostles
I
Like can't hit him, but he can hit me
Again too soon
I know this is if he cuz his cat hair keep having to move my stuff
Me the gods can apostle when me is a god-skinned Apostle
Yeah, he knows it, you know, she's the God-skinned Apostle
Come on
No, I took forever do that animation
Oh
Why don't I feel like I'm too heavy
Okay
Okay, all right, it looks like I have to
Since I can't get him to the second phase and so many attempts
I will
Use the mimic tear I
Didn't want to but I am just not good enough
It sucks
If I was playing this by myself without streaming I probably would have
Done this like in a billion attempts, but I don't want to do it in a billion attempts
Can you get out of there dude like why are you
I don't think the mimic tears gonna help I
Don't
That one like jam into the ground thing is interesting
Because I'll just take too long if I don't use this I'm in but like I like to like try to do stuff by myself, you know
Probably should have done the thing first
Are you not locked on me
Why is that last forever
I
Spock yeah, I was like, where's this
Oh
Okay, well now I know I can beat him with the the mimic tears, so
Well, he's looking at me all funny
He stops often over here, let's see if I can get behind him
I'm just trying to get behind
Yeah, I know it's good. I know the moment I jumped I was gonna die
You cursed it you cursed it bro
You're gonna stretch in your paw paws out
I
Don't
I probably went too far away. I thought he was still aggroed on me and my nose
No, I was paying attention to my health
Nine nine
Thanks for stopping by
Oh, come on I'm tired of this grandpa
What oh I was in the
Why was it working before when I was like that close
No, I'm not gonna laser I don't have a Zers comment. I think I have to have until the minor intelligence of like
I
Also just don't have a good mimic here to be honest
Come on dude, I was
Like I
Don't know how he's like literally just like to shoddy me so easily
Maybe I should have done 60 bigger cuz this is ridiculous
I
Yeah, that's what I was trying. I'm like kind of trying to spam through his first phase
And get to the like try to get him as low as possible with the mimic here
You know, I should like I said, I should be not doing the mimic here until I do this
But you know the physics, but I don't know if that matters. I can't remember if they can't use physics or not
You
Back up
Come on get out of your stupid fire
Oh
I
Again he two shots me again he two shots me
Okay, you know what I feel like maybe
And do this first maybe if I already have the
Physics when I summon I don't know if that helps it. I don't know if this gets affected by that to be honest with you
I
Think he's already he's already almost dead
And
I can't repost him cuz I'm in his fucking thing
I
Didn't see my health. Yeah, I'm sorry. I'm sorry guys. I I didn't see my health. I didn't see my health
I didn't see my health. I'm sorry
I'm not gonna heal until I feel like I actually need it
Think I've been using up a flask and I don't really need you yet
Like now would be a good time like now would be a great time
How am I getting hit by that see the freaking things almost dead and I don't have time
I
Maybe I need to do heavy attacks
Why are you so cute? I'm thinking I need to do heavy attacks instead of I've just been yeah
I
Honestly think I might get more
Back up back up
Can't get close to do this
Did you just see did you see him one shot me I
I
Only had maybe like I probably had like 70% health and he was able to one shot me
That that doesn't make any sense I didn't know he could do that I didn't know that hit those so that was that strong
I
Back up back up back up
Oh
My god
Come on get that blood proc get that blood proc. Oh, thank you
If you could just spam through his second phase you're literally golden. Thank you mimic tear appreciate you boo
All right
Sick I needed that reposs so bad. I needed that reposs
Again I didn't want to use the mimic tear, but I'm just not that good. I'll get better. I'll try my best. Just
That's how pull me
You're looking at the cat TV from the bed
All right, Micaela, what the hell hey
Yeah, totally sorry don't mind my sword just in my hand
Micaela the poopoo head
I really just want to play this for like ten hours
And tell the realm of shadow
Give him a kissy. I'm gonna kiss the ring not like giant Micaela's hand
Oh
All right, what's over here? Oh, at least I can bring toilet. Oh nothing
I don't know why this reminds me a pal world like this one step out like this
whoa
Again, I haven't seen anything like I've only seen the boss arenas. So this is
Crazy. Oh, it's cool. It's like a veil. I think that's something about like crossing the veil
And that's why Micaela had to do what he did
to um
Get into the
Realm of shadow, you know, it's interesting. I just noticed so on the earth tree
There is a portion of the bark that is dark
And it's funny that on the scudoo tree. There's a portion of the bark
That is gold and what's interesting
I can't recall if Merica made the scudoo tree or when
Because again the realm of shadow used to be
Part
Of the lands between normally. Oh, there's a lot of stuff falling from that
Um until Merica separated it to hide her past. Oh god. I can see the fire golem from here
um
He is
standing menacingly
So it's it's quite interesting
It's funny that Merica's grace is here because usually I believe there's not a lot of great graces
Um
I can't I don't I have to get glove work for that
And I brought I kind of want to go through stuff
That's why there's like no enemies like jumping out of the grass that one
He's like, what are these things?
Like statues or are there
Things I have to fight
I kind of just want to see that as a thing I have to fight
Oh, you were interesting
Oh
The thing you're weak to magic
What are you? What did I just kill? I don't even know
Just killing things willy-nilly
Uh
Oh interesting
What are you guys you guys look like the equivalent of the old guy that points at stuff below but
No, interesting interesting
Yeah, yeah, I'll I'll do scadoo shadow shadow tree
Well, I'm going to call it a scadoo tree
The scabba da-da-da-da-da-do. I'm a scatree
bup, bup, bup, bup, bup, bup
I'm going to go to this tree over here
Because it looks like there's a map anyways
Skadoo shtree
Nine nine. Oh
The tree
the tree are you coming to the tree strange thing has happened
right yeah and i know like this is really essentially big if not bigger than the base game
map which is very very very cool to me uh i thought it would be a lot smaller
well these guys are just hanging out just hanging around silly
i thought there was something over here but it's just sheep and
uh white flesh we love to see it um i'm probably gonna do a lot here this is gonna be
hours again for longevity sake i don't know it's
it's if it's if i should even bother um i thought there was gonna be a map here another one i got
too giddy like showing you guys everything to be honest probably like all the bosses and stuff
but like i'm gonna be doing a lot of exploration and all that um and i don't know for like from
a content creator standpoint if it would be good for algorithmic reasons to keep playing this online
um yeah okay i like because i want to show you guys everything and then like i probably will
do like maybe an Elden Ring Stream like once a week and i just literally just endurance it the
entire time to be honest with you guys um okay how are you guys doing i'm so sorry that you guys
are stuck in the shadow realm um pardon thank you i have to crack pot don't know what i'm gonna do
with that i'll probably put something in it go over here sorry i just like i want to explore
although i know i could literally just do this on torrent i didn't mean to sound like a mimic
here but it's fine it doesn't matter bird's dropping in hot this game is so beautiful
what are you oh doesn't say your name
what the heck are these thingies they remind me of the things in the ocean
and what can i touch it they're kind of just hanging out this one's different
oh okay i can't bump into them
what this this is all already a thing there's a mausoleum here well let's check it out wait
how much i have a lot of runes let me let me go back i'll i'll jump back over there
back which is our power things oh we finally beat moag thank you jackson for the soup
uh so let's get that vigor up queen
literally perfect for 55 i'm just gonna do that i need all the vigor i can get
i'm sorry miss jackson i am my favorite thing is like it's like a picture of four guys um
in suits but they have eels for heads i am for eels how's the game going um
i finally just beat moag i was getting a little disheartened because i was sad that i couldn't do
it without the ash uh with the the mimic here summon um but you know i'll get good
i probably honestly do a new game on my playstation and try to play actually i'll play with my
i think i'm trying to remember what level i am i think maybe i'm like 150 yeah i want to fight
whatever's in here if it's a dancing line i'm just gonna leave
it's a black gal jail night all right now oh oh my god
oh my lord you do so much damage what the hell
oh holy you're gonna two shot me oh my god that's incredible well goodbye 20k rooms
wow like yeah literally looks like guts there's a bazillion berserk references in this game
um literally the poise monster
i kind of want to play i kind of want to i kind of want to my play back as we
happen sometimes i kind of want to try again i just want to see how much damage i do at him
to be honest with you
oh i don't do shit
can i get like anything off on you oh yeah no i'm done i'm done so bro
oh that's cool i want to i bet he i bet you get his crossbow i bet you get his crossbow
damn he one shot me i didn't think that move was gonna be that heavy that's so cool though
that's crazy um i'm trash oh i didn't mean to do that that's fine
that's true because i need to get the scotty tree blessings the shadow tree
blessings the game loads a lot slower interesting um without the base game
uh i know this golem is absolutely ridiculous uh it's 10 times stronger than the freaking fire
giant which i was trash at um i like how these burbs are just hanging out
i wish i could get things to aggro each other this is like it's so cool looking though like
look how cool this thing is like what ouch uh ouch uh but you're really cool please don't jump on me
i need to lock on no not lock on to you oh my god just freaking amazing enemy like
look how crazy the shot looks right now oh my god this game is gorgeous i'm dead it's fine
i'm just admiring the enemies
i literally watched like an hour long uh video by like elden ring fights and it's like
who can kill the fire golem and it literally like the fire giant died to the fire golem it was like
it it has so much health it's like over it's more help oh i was still alive i didn't even notice that
um it's fine i'm geek i'm just geeking it has more health than the elden ring beast i'm pretty sure
uh it's not like i have any runes i don't care
uh
i'm surprised that doesn't have a state america
snake america
yeah i loved yeah very tanky very but also it's like
ridiculously tanky because it's just powerful at the same time um scorch runes interesting uh
i've never i don't know anything about this
i don't know if stuff is worth like oh cool i know there's a potentate every what the potentate
is about or reading about the potentate it's just it's just there's also just a lot of rare items
what the heck is that you click little what are you golems big gargoyles i can't even tell
um i hope you guys enjoy your sleep i'm just gonna run around and explore this is a cool tree
i'm literally just geeking out right now because i just love this game so so much oh what are you
talking about what do you got to say are you serious you can attack me i hate that they
can attack you i wish you had like invincibility when you um when you were talking to an npc sometimes
all right let me go back and talk with you because i actually wanted to see what you had to say
i know only resentment lingers yet the raw stuff from which i shall surely forge curse upon the
dastard mesmer's head upon america's children each and all sick thank you for that um i do have
more to say why did you get like bluer interesting i don't know why i came with blue
is another one is it the same one that i saw from far away i don't even know
sick sick sick
broken rune interesting what's up with that
technically funny because all the runes are shards of the elden ring so they're all technically
broken mushroom kind of want to look at this cookbook that i got hold on i think i'm safe here
famous last words um yeah i can see a dude coming all right hold on can you guys chill
got stuff to do i got people to see
what did i get with the cookbook
i don't even know
i feel like i didn't get anything from that
so
oh all right
all right cool cool cool well i'm not messing with that thing because i'm not a silly goose um
what's that over there this is really like the best game for someone with adhg because you just
you don't have to follow a linear path or maybe it's the worst game for that reason some of these
gravestones like gold so i feel like i need to go to them am i gonna hurt myself no okay surprising um
uh yes the spirals the crucible is a spiral spirals a very very holy thing reaching up towards
the heavens i love to see it isn't raining it rains here they got clouds like that
i heard the backhand blade it was very good for a first run um
um
i don't know what type of blade is it
slash pierce blind spot
oh very bloodhounds fang
it's very it's so cool i like how you hold it very cool wielding style
two-handed oh sorry oh my god what
what hello
oh my god i'm gonna freaking bible all over the place dude i i need to read a verse
sorry i'm gonna try to kill y'all uh oh my god this is a blood build up because that would be sick
oh my god i'm so fast
i'm so fast
oh you like come from the side oh my god
wow
i'm having the time of my life
oh my god this is sick oh you guys got nothing on me i just breaking your poise
what does this glass poise y'all have oh my god
oh this is glorious oh i love this wow there's more of you and i'm pretty sure he's healing you
oh you guys are holding like runes they're holding the the rune what the heck that's so cool
are these horns sent i can't tell uh yes they are i couldn't tell if there are horns on their heads
or not that's interesting that like really breaks their poise when i do that i didn't even lock on
it did that ow very good range oh my god
oh my god and i'm going for this one then i can oh my i'm having the time of my life hold
shut up dude i know i should be killing you but like i want to kill your little followers first
i'm gonna be playing with so many weapons i love two-handing weapons i i usually don't
though for games like this because there's usually just aren't weapons to two-handle
and sometimes these games
and it doesn't consume fp to do this which is interesting
this is just so sick
all right
can you stay in motion while running doing and doing a what
well i don't know what that means
i'm sorry
fist like i don't really like fist weapons i don't mind claws though
well i'm not gonna i'm not gonna use this i will be using my moon veil until i find something
just as worthy again because this is a plus 10 weapon i'm not gonna just not use it
i worked hard for the plus 10 um but i will like mess around for stuff what is over there
what's over here oh that's a can't go over there um can you hold on i like really
want to check my map to see if there's a way to cross uh i think it's down this way nope
all right yeah let's just divide so i'm naturally drawn to go over here i see michaels cross
they're doing dual lightning axes oh my god from soft you're spoiling us
i never did a claw build or any like play what is that
um are y'all gonna kill me who are y'all y'all is hanging out
sick scottish fragments can be found across the realm of shadow consume these at sites of
grace to bolter your scottish blessing the scottish blessing bolters or subordinatibilities
deal and negate damage has no influence outside the realm of shadow i like that they did that
because it makes sense unless you're doing like new game plus stuff but it like it's pretty sick
i'm trying to become a god hold on i read this and um melina's voice
carved words coalesce i abandon here the first of the flesh of my body of my body
i can't really do that she does like a weird thing premium blood version who are you
you look like you have a bum hole for a face oh aren't you one of the horn you're the caterpillar
dude that does terrible things what woman you're a really cool voice actor
and your kind are not forgiven that's not nice by marica long betrayed set aflame
i believe michela's apologies when he says i'll delivery will come but never will i see your
kind as worthy okay i kind of want to kill you for that
i'm very tempted to kill you for that but i won't because i know you do stuff other times
um you know what's really funny to me i don't get why michela wants to help him because if you
think if you know anything spoilers it'll head if you know anything about marica's backstory
that's revealed in this she is newman this is the the realm of shadow which was once part of
the lands between normally until she separated it because she wanted to hide her past uh the newmen
were very much abused by the horn sent um and then because of that marica punished them because they
forced them into these horrible jars and whipped them and tortured them and did all this terrible
things so i don't know why michela is trying to redeem these people um obviously michela wants
his own order which is totally fine um but he just said he just said he's gonna he's gonna do stuff
horn sent him on wrongly and completely did nothing wrong must create saints
you know and it's funny because i'm like how does that make them a saint
like how does that canonize that and i'm really i'm more interested in that process oh my gosh
we're like almost the same height what's up queen yeah a teeth whip i've seen the teeth whip um
he's very yeah best ashes award yeah that's why i'm not gonna i'm not gonna kill him because
i know he gives us something good um but michela isn't a kid he's just he's just he
he michela kind of reminds me of the um
the trope of like innocence being or like the abuse of more innocent things being inherently
evil or like innocent things can be like you know that like trope of like crazy characters
drinking milk like homelander clockwork orange um i'm pretty sure there was one like
one flew over the cuckoo's nest i can't remember um but like i know it's like a very like stanley
cubrick thing um and like michela is such an interesting character to me because he is this
he's a demigod he's about to become a god he's an imperian he is a god he's been around for a long
time his curse is eternal childhood but that necessarily i feel like in my opinion that
doesn't mean that he thinks like a child because like it's clear his aspirations of godhood are
not childlike i feel like if he was a child he wouldn't really be interested in those things
that was rena who was me out in the background um
and i feel like he takes his youthful appearance his innocence looking nature michela the kind and
that's like he uses you know his ability is to sway people and have people like be devoted to him
and fall in love with him um yeah but he's so he's so deluded though and what he thinks is kind
that he is forcing other people to do things for him much like a kid would like a kid kids
are master manipulators um they will say things to try to get their way and they will convince you
and then sometimes some people are pushovers because they're like oh they're a kid let's give
them what they want and so it's very interesting like michela's character is very very interesting
to me um yeah he's generally good intentions very deluded but he goes around the wrong way uh just
like and that kind of just shows like uh because a god we think of a god a god is supposed to be a
perfect being and it's interesting i think i was like listening to something where it's like it's a
different type of godhood when you have something imperfect becoming a god for the wrong reasons
and that's why michela is very like jesus like because you think like oh like michela's feels uh
feels right now feels obligated to wipe away marica's sin um whatever that was i still
am unsure what the sin is uh i've seen lots of different things about what the sin could be um
um and uh
she'd be speaking from yeah i'm speaking from experience no i was a very good kid i was quiet
kept my head down i was i was sweet um it seems to be a theme of life wanting to join together yes
yeah put new ninja because i said the new men were very good for melding things together
they're like perfect for that um and again i think that comes back to like with the new men
and uh the horn sent with the jars you think of a spiral uh you could these things twisting
up each other so it does make sense to why they would they would say that as like a sainthood
and also because the spiral is heavily inspired um it's a crucible they worship the crucible uh
they worship the power of the crucible essentially they just see this as a spiral
same thing and the crucible is just wild uh primordial primeval power um
and so it makes sense they want everything to be conjoined and wrapped up because they are chaos
like if you look at a horn sent they are just they don't make any sense they have vestigial
organs horns limbs on a bunch of other stuff he's interesting to me because he looks pretty
normal to be honest with you uh he doesn't look like a normal horn like he has a couple of horns
but he looks fairly normal to me which is interesting he's one of the more humanoid horn sent uh and
because they're all omen like they're omen they all came from omen and omen came from the crucible
and stuff um marica's sin is everything come do with god oh she did after but she came one
yeah exactly uh but i feel like it's more like i feel like there's like when michela talks about
marica's sin i feel like it's something in particular because he doesn't say sins the sins
of my mother or the like he said the sin of merit like it's a singular sin and i forget i remember
listening to what it possibly could be but i can't recall um i might have to like look that up again
yeah all things came from i were conjoined by the crucible perhaps they thought that
melding they'll make them a saint because they would be in their mind melded back together
exactly so i think and i'm just discovering that right now as we're talking about it because i'm
just like why would they why i was thinking when i was listening to lore and stuff i'm like why are
they trying to make them saints does it make any sense to me um isn't there like nine
nine scatter tree blessings or something or like 10 what is this what does that do i don't even know
what that is um but like it's funny to me that like if the if the genocide of the horn sent
or the attempt to genocide of the horn sent is what it is her original sin
it doesn't
because you gotta think like is it justified because like i get is it really a sin if the greater
will doesn't care because all the greater will cares about his order the greater will is a seriously
like in a different god who just wants some sort of order in the world um i'm so glad you're on this
channel so now here you talk like this is so fun uh 21st god okay um
her actual first lord maybe that's a good that's a good one um
and i'm wondering if it's a sin becoming a god as she because she isn't doing she didn't do the
things that michael is doing so michael is at least shedding his flesh he's becoming he's
ascending as a spirit he's attaining this higher sense of enlightenment and i feel like maybe
that's what he means like he was she was sullied he didn't like she like she did do imperfect things
yes she did do horrible things before um but she went in i feel like i don't recall if she went in
as a in a fleshly form through the gate um
uh yeah it wasn't god-free it wasn't god-free wasn't uh yeah um
but like it seemed like like because they describe it as like a seduction
and i'm like it's so it's like a manipulation of something or someone or something like and so and
then again i'm wondering if it's a seduction manipulation of like the entirety of the lands
between to become a god uh yes i know about me there because i was gonna say you think about
the fingers and there is a distinct thing about the fingers that says
the fingers were never like to be trusted in the first place like they've only
they're kind of doing like the greater will has actually spoilers spoilers everybody spoilers
the greater will had given up on the lands between america's order and the golden order
a long ago it was not using the fingers to talk to people like you so the so the um
the greater will use the fingers as emissaries but the fingers were a c which was a big twist
i remember losing my mind at this listening to dlc stuff that um because again i'm not the person
who goes through when i play a game and i look at all the like i would never know any of the stuff
unless i watch something about it because i don't go and try to grab every new item um
uh yeah they they stopped having communication before america was even ever became gone and
then it's interesting because then you think of like uh time is relative thing um time is a very
interesting thing in the lands between uh people live so long people don't die but even like before
like the elden ring was shattered and all that stuff and there was death and everything um oh
hi boomi hey yo he left and came back hi were you checking on rena um boomi maybe you'll forget
my train of thought with your cuteness uh yeah like and so it's like it's almost like
like they got a telegram and it was so delayed
and it was also really cryptic and it's like and it's it's so interesting because then you're
like oh my god everything we've been doing is a lie then why am i the elden lord like why how
and it's like it seems like even power is delayed like it seems like the greater world because
obviously and maybe the greater will views time as something you know
elden ring morally has more lore than the bible uh i think the elden ring has just as much lore as
the bible to be honest um there it definitely has its moments i feel like culturally there's a lot
more lore but spiritually i'd say they're on the same kind of par um just with more of like a
pantheon of gods or just like uh energies and forces the kami um yeah the greater will believe
made her uh made her to be cut corrupt which stops communicating which is funny because
you think because you're like okay but the elden beast then how why why do you fight the elden
beast and then because the elden beast is also a vassal of the greater will that comes about
after you defeat radigan uh if he needs an elden ring fungus
golden order is problematic because based on whims and contrasts what was before
yes and it's like it's funny because the crucible order or like the order what like were the dragons
when uh parthenon acts were the i never can remember the dragon's names uh plasuda sacks
was the elden lord i again i'm so curious as to what god and what order was about when
plasuda sacks was the elden lord um and what god was he a consort to very very interesting to me
uh yeah ancient dragon's stone sails they could twist time god that wants to rule them and they
came yeah that's why i'm like who is this god what is it is the is it the outer god or god of time
because time is death because again all the outer gods are based on some concept of death
um the dragons followed a different god yes
parthenax is from skyrim so oh my god i'm so so leave me alone parthenax plasuda sacks
uh
i love skyrim that's why i like elden ring too um
no i i have marathon a lot of bodies videos but a lot of bodies videos are not up to date
um i will probably watch the more recent body videos i've been watching a lot of smoke town
uh because i really like uh his take on things but like yeah the last because the body videos
he made like two years ago and there's so much more stuff since then and he hasn't updated any of
the videos he needs to yeah bale i have i know bale's a dragon i'm not super familiar with bale
though i don't know a lot about um bale's lord dragon never seen yeah and then you think about like
how dragons have changed like you have this sense of like you see plasuda sacks
four wings four legs three heads um already have four heads i don't i don't remember but it's at
first i it's interesting to me because you think of like four wings three heads and like you think
of the number seven and seven's a very divine number but then you think of the dragons that you
see like the modern day dragons in the base game and they are essentially wyverns or like i don't
know what the heck they're called they have two legs and their hands are on their wings
he had five interesting uh yeah i couldn't remember how many heads he had um but i feel
like i feel like the number of limbs that plasuda sacks has does have some sort of significance
four wings four legs five heads like i feel like there's a reason for that um i don't know what it
is but yeah i feel like how to do maybe with some like i don't know i have to think about that somewhere
um oh which is he want to be the dragon oh okay yeah there was so you think about like how they
have degenerated over time and how cultures have changed how evolution has happened and evolution
takes a very very very long time you think of like the beastman of fair mazula um two and
how it was like like how they're in a state of suspended time because you think like okay all
this evolution has happened why haven't they evolved
and that was the reason plasuda sacks is in his out of time arena and bale still has two
oh yeah oh because bale's fight i only start for literally like a brief second so i didn't even notice
that isn't the game lord just theory what are you talking about
god i can't stay up this is yeah that makes sense that makes sense because he's really
he he was so powerful that you don't think that godwin could
you know destroy him the way he did because god was insane that's really cool i didn't even know
that that's pretty cool actually that's really cool um but yeah i'm super
super super interested with a bunch of stuff in this game uh like i again i'm a sucker for
world building i'm a sucker for lore uh georgia martin although he's incredibly annoying because
you won't finish the rest of the books and probably never will before he dies he probably
will release it when he dies um he he just hopped on my lap he is such an amazing world
him and miizaki have made this incredible meld of so many cultures and religions because you have
like japanese religion and culture and a lot of shintoism um involved and then you have like
irish english it's so like it really is like as you can hear in my voice i like i geek out so
hard about it because i'm a sucker for oh sorry i didn't mean to press that um
um what listen i just want to talk can i talk don't don't be don't madem we got more npcs to
see and talk i don't care i'm gonna do this for everyone i will go in a tangent after i talk to
one npc fine i'll talk to him oh my god rena you have a sick helm
oh aren't you like um yeah radon's lady and you're really sad about radon sick
dour him
wait did you have more to say where'd he go
if michael it is who you would seek these are the sites i urge you follow after
our dour little friend cool thanks i appreciate it appreciate you follow after michela as long
as you abide but okay see because like you think of what he just said he's like you'll be no enemy
to me because you're by me michela but like
what sets apart what michela is doing but it's little it's literally the master manipulation
like a freaking michela's powers that just draws in everybody because he's also a freaking maniac
and he's really no different from his mother he's does it in different ways okay sorry
egon and bail are based off of cap and ahem and will be no way that's so cool
i had a moment where i binged a lot of classic literature like um will be dick picture dory and
gray um because this is because of an extra league of extraordinary gentlemen because i was like
reading all the books vantals sing all that stuff jackal and hide
his mother father michela wants everyone to get along he doesn't have them this free will
what i want to know more of is i want to know more of melina's role in all this because you
think of like okay uh spoiler spoiler spoiler spoiler spoiler uh we know that melina and mesmer
are america's children from radigan uh because you know everybody has freaking red hair um
and it's interesting to me
that melina doesn't seem to have the same so like all the children of uh america and radigan
are cursed because they are born from the same singular god technically and just they're just
two halves to a whole um which is again like its own like insetuous thing um and that's why it's
almost like akin to family members doing stuff and like passing something down to their kids
that could be an issue um and like you think of mesmer who has the abyssal serpent you have
you know michela being cursed to be the child and then you have um melania being cursed to
have be a vessel and a vessel of the scarlet rot and become try to be like she has to become the
goddess of rot and have a order of rot um but yeah um that's what i was gonna say i'm like is melina's
saying as she does about physical body however you have to think about the past in terms of like
if you delve into the origins of the godskin apostles uh excuse me by the way i didn't mean to
burp and you know that you know melina is more than likely the glomide queen she used to have
some physical form until i forget if it was who was it was a i forget who it was another demigod
or it was america removed from her body
and almost like like killed her and destroyed her so she destroyed her physical body because like
again do themes of duality in elden ring you have a physical body and a spiritual body so
so michael is able to separate himself from the um straitstrina which makes sense so america and
radigan can make kids do you have the same hole that could split yes yes yeah yep yep i knew that um
makes sense radigan fought renola was the meager champion will america use a god yeah
because i feel like it's like their opposites almost again
and divine masculine divine feminine this red hair i feel like
it's weird because you think about america and radigan and so you think of like okay
there's this parallel of light versus darkness is radigan light
in america darkness or do or is radigan darkness because of his fervorous attempt
for the golden order you know
i'm escaping so much every time i'm talking as she would talk about healer i know me too
in the same way none of them are like well yeah like everybody it's everybody's morally gray
here it's very yin and yang yes again another um eastern uh belief system philosophy
incorporated into the game
i find it funny how from pot software keeps removing mentions of melina what do you mean
but i feel i feel like that would be done on purpose in a way that it's like oh my god america
is removing her because like you don't like you have you obviously know why melina i mean america
doesn't abandon mesmer because she's scared of his ability with the abyssal serpent
in this you know serpents are very again there's a lot of parallels to like
the bible and stuff because serpents are seen as evil like constantly throughout the base game
um and i i i actually wondered if the the the serpent was the god in um the base game
uh because you see a lot of like dead serpents and stuff
radigan is trying to go back to his roots america had a break tries to branch out and move on
but again my personal opinion is that radigan came to be when america attained her godhood
i don't think that they were separate people and i feel like that's it's evidence through saint
michela that once you attain the sort of godhood or close to you have this split
sister i got removed oh yeah i heard about that but it said like
now now isn't it more vague now that like his sister also had a vision of fire his younger sister
they just said it like that or did they remove that line completely because that would be very
interesting to me yeah serpent is blasphemy but i feel like the serpents more than that like the
abyssal serpent is a newer well not like a newer but like an outer god and it's very so she like
you know throw throws him away but why why does she do this with me why does she try to scrub melina
from everything before because i'm like there must have been a trigger just like how ronnie's just
like you know like f everything like what cosmolina be like you know what i'm making these gods
can apostles i'm gonna start destroying everybody the sister mentioned is gone completely really
really that is so interesting to me
i generally wonder why that is then they got rid of that whole sister part
did they think they were giving too much away or did they think they didn't want us to run with
the melina stuff that is really interesting to me but it's only a finger does in a power
to communicate to the chaos flame uh right camera call
what are the three fingers a sort of bad child a meter someone she'd been making the chaos flame
i don't think i i didn't have to disagree with that because i there is a chaotic frenzied flame god
outer god so i feel like that's just i do believe that that probably like the three fingers was like
a black sheep child and it kind of was just like i'm doing my own thing um which does it and it's
obviously uh there's this thing of like order and independence and like you have to conform um
and it's interesting that one of the the three fingers didn't want to conform to be part of the hand
and they got rid of these people but it's like i thought that was a really good tidbit
the fact that they said like the younger sister also our visions of the flame
but that's what's good i like the questions the questions make people think that's why i like
from soft games because a lot of stuff is open-ended just like the map
i think it's a whole new being once they reach a certain level power they start to achieve the power
of creation and then be part of themselves into the new being is god of creative life
i agree with that i agree with that 100
uh
i i bet i would totally anticipate in like two years they do another one a dlc just to wrap
everything up i don't know maybe or they just add like stuff to the game like patches um
like gate patches not the actual character patches um yeah no she's way more than two fingers
i like her name is meter like meter because it's like i forget that like means something
it's like i means like 10 like it's like digits like fingers and so i'm like ah i like it
personally they said they were done i would not honestly patches is a god patches is a god
he's bounces around games like he's some like universe hopper
yeah i love china lord theories too first the fingers is all otherworldly yeah
yeah or mar or it also can be assigned like with martyr
yeah again i don't know soldier of god rick yeah i always thought that was silly
he's also crazy he's the hardest he hardest boss in the game i could never beat him that's why
like i avoided him when we were playing the base game soldier of god rick no way um again i don't know
uh i didn't know about dlc stuff just speculating um
but i feel like i feel like if i like this is the most popular fronts from soft game in a
like pop one of the most popular games in a very very long time i feel like if another
people enough people clamored for it they would do something or like surprise people tarnish mortium
god rick yeah that's why i skipped the beginning cave i'm like why would i put myself in this
situation just like with the grafted scion you know um but yeah i could literally just sit and
talk about that for hours because you think of like okay if the greater will does not want to
and like turned away from the golden order and stuff what is it doing now like what what's up
what's it waiting for what is it again in a time why do i feel like i don't know which way to go
i'm gonna go this way first actually um and time is relative and stuff so for this outer this this
crazy god it probably looked at stuff it was like yeah no i'm not dealing with this and um
like looked away like 15 minutes is like 15 million years for it oh what's this
oh okay cool um
um
dang this is this is i forget how big this game is gonna be uh crazy dlc
over
hmm okay there's more over here
and there's stuff over okay that's probably where that gate is and that's probably like the first
thing this might be like dungeon thingy fascinating fascinating i might try to go and get the maps
because again i'm i'm like that i'm a map girl uh i'll probably cross the bridge and try to get
through that i don't actually know if this doesn't seem like it'd be a good way to do it
now i'm looking at this um i might have to cut through whatever this thing is yeah looks like
there's a way to do it here then go down here and then here and then go up here
you might do that i'll go check on what these are first uh the crosses with michela
okay i'm assuming these are them what is this then no because michela's crosses looks is
decide uh so i don't know why he gave me this map if it's literally just like this and then he
did like this why did he
hmm
oh yeah i know the map is huge
so
map goes the cave it's not yet too there's three i've heard there was like great sword katanas
which is so interesting to me
the map goes by the cave i said no oh is that what that is oh i thought it was that direction
hmm well i'll go wherever the wind takes me oh look at grace
yeah that's why i hated mount trying to get the map near mount gilmere what's over here
ooh i'm blue die by d die by die is something gonna attack me
oh larval tear interesting i actually haven't grabbed any larval tears because i haven't
killed anything though drop it
here we go please don't whip me
please don't shove me in a jar
oh wait hold on i gotta put on my my reverb for this
help me i must ask am i human still is that the reason i yet suffer so
not that you are
yeah i know about that area um i thought there was something in here i think i might be thinking
in different places isn't the bonnie village again i know a little bit about areas oh i don't
like y'all oh at least okay at least i do do some damage to y'all okay that's cool i'm happy i have
the moon veil then
cool nifty we love to see it um we got in here hello hello something gonna drop down on me
broken room interesting
i hate to be mesmer just be abandoned by your mom you're just like hanging out trying to
do her crusade and you're taking all the like crap people hate you and you just did it in the
name of your mother and but you gotta pretend it was just you sucks
sucks bro
what's going on here
you guys good what are you guys looking at
huh i'm looking at the wrong thing but it's fine oh y'all are interesting looking
oh you're like little bugs can i get out of here can i like lock on something
what is oh you're like legit interesting it's like doing bleed damage hold on let me just
come down here oh what did those things respond they're like little mosquitoes
oh it's gonna kill me
what is that
there you go
what the heck
oh well that's nifty
dlc's just florida
why is it blue like i'll just change his color when i enter this area like oh there's nothing in
there let the bodies hit the floor
or
ailment talisman
oh okay that's pretty cool that's pretty cool um i guess i don't really need the golden scarab
because i don't think it attacking will it work here i don't think so because i'm not getting real
ruins
pardon
Sorry, gotta go. Sorry. My people need me. Sorry. I
Gotta go I gotta go I
Gotta go I gotta go. Sorry
Took me a while, but I got there. Oh
I mean unless these guys drop something fly mold other flies disgusting
So, yeah, it looks like like you guys said a lot of the
Stuff is cool. Oh my god is a cut a part. I
Wish I had the telescope cuz I don't have it
Very cool. Oh, we've no that makes so much. Why are there no water? Oh, oh
That can be there's something down there
What what is that is that the
It's at the bore dude the guy that rides the bore. I can't remember
the BFF the the the Biffle of
Mesmer
Looks like a Sentinel what is that
Crab
I
Was like, what is that?
Why can I summon spirit ashes here, I'll say the tree looks terrifying in the distance a lot of things look terrifying in the distance
It's cool. There's waterfalls with everything. That's how things are spaced out even in the base game
You think there'd be more waterfalls
Yeah, the area is definitely don't connect like you think they should. Oh, oh, all right, Torrent, that's fine
You don't have to show up or nothing. That's let's let's say, okay
Oh, oh, oh anybody in there
Can I get off my horse piece, I don't know like Torrent just doesn't want to behave
I
Sorry about that I'm just gonna do whatever that is get your body off of me with your little weirdy spindly legs
Ghosts doggies
Jump over the ghost doggy run away from the ghost doggy
Sorry, I'm just like skirting around the edge just to see stuff
Very cool
What I thought those were something else they look weird for far away why there's like regular eagles here
That's just so funny to me. They're like, oh, yeah, we came from the top. You know
Gravebird armor cool
Don't know what that will do
Well, I don't know. Oh, that one has bonus rooms, but I don't really care right now
And Kayla
What? Oh wait, uh, I can't remember. Did you guys say yes that would affect it or no? I
Didn't see because I was riding around. Oh
Whoa, look at the moon. It's like the moon has has sigils in it
Oh, yeah, I like them the moon
Um a dark moon whatever the heck with like Ronnie and stuff her own order
Very interesting kind of want to learn more about that and but like cuz you think about like
Nox Stella and them trying to make their night prince or night king or whatever the heck it's called. I can't remember
Very cool
Shadow realm room
Okay, oh, yeah, they're a different symbol and
Tarasante
Where am I?
Oh looks like I pretty much have to go. Oh back over here
This carib does work here, okay
Why am I none cuz I'm holy
Well when we just stretched and put his paw on my arm, that's very sweet
Wait a second. Oh
Yeah, cuz this goes under here so I would need to go this way
Let's try it. Oh
My god something. I don't know if a skunk sprayed outside or I don't know if somebody's like I
Think like my downstairs neighbor is smoking that stuff makes me so nauseous I
hate that I
Need to get like those like
Filter things because I have an air thing. Oh for god that I can't just go straight
There's a bridge
I
Didn't get more of those like air filter things
Need to change my air filter in my air purifier
I know boomies literally this is this is this is this is cuteness for us to the month
Oh surprise like nothing is on this bridge. I'm probably gonna get shot
Come on
Where's the trebuchet?
Where's the giant freaking arrows, where's the flaming balls of fire? Oh, are those are aionian butterflies?
Oh, no, they're black pyre flies
Interesting. Oh, there it is. Oh
I missed I want to pick up everything
Ballistable, okay
Hey, what's up? I
Believe oh, well, I'm gonna get the grace. I believe there's a scato cheese blessing nearby. Oh
Yep scato cheese fragment
Can I okay
Yeah
You need the fingersling blades
Yeah, that's a good point actually
No, I need to
Sure
At least it's fine like it's very it's very forgiving if you're on a brand new game
It's probably be on my horse
Or not hello, I
like how like
It's very interesting
Because you kind of when you're playing as like the tarnish and you're in enemy camps and stuff
You kind of see them as like heathens, but then you kind of you go into it like oh really?
Oh, it is implied that people sat here and ate this table, but you never really think about that
As far as nobody's coming out of the tent just like
ripping me a new one
Like they had people that set up the tent and like to get food and then people will set up all these pikes
Must smell like terrible around here
What is I just real oh
Yeah, and it's like interesting cuz America's beheaded and you think about like I feel like this is a what the heck
I'm just shaking. Can I do that again?
Maybe that again come on
do it I
was saying I
Was thinking of like how this kind of reminds me to have how a lot of Egyptian statues were defaced and like their noses cut off and like
Certain features were cut off
I
Believe I think somebody said that it's like mesmer
Cut off all the heads of the America statues a careful
All right. Hey, bye. I don't really feel like fighting you
I know there's another scot-o-tree thing around here somewhere. I
Know it
Have a vague feeling
So they remember watching a video briefly if somebody was running through and they happened to run through something
That looked like a camp like this and there is a scot-o-tree fragment. Oh
That was a review don't just shot at my face
Oh, that's a cool-looking dog terrifying, but cool
Oh, hey you
Perfumers. Oh, yeah, I never got the idea of perfumers. I never used anything that perfumers had
Is anything in here? No. Oh, I'm gonna die. I don't want to get hurt
Cuz about not the bosses, but like the things are very unforgiving. Oh
Oh, you look intense. Oh, yeah. Yeah, you are. Oh, oh
Oh, please. Oh, please don't kill me. I can't see past this stupid dialogue box
Don't mind me. I am just crashing through your camp looking for stuff to seal
Nothing major. Don't worry about it. Stop
It's very rude. I'm just trying to steal stuff. Oh my god. It's a freaking dog. Oh, what's that? I don't know. I need a sneeze
Like how you just have a dead person in there. I mean not gonna hit by that torch
Hello
How I don't even know what I got hit with
Thank you
Perfumes are cool because like I just never saw the point of them because again, they're very late game
Because it doesn't tell really until like the alt is plateau
Uh, you deal with like perfumers
But like I don't I'll be honest. I don't really know what they're for like the perfumes. Where's my stuff over there?
I know it's only like 20k, but
Girls gotta do what a girl's gotta do
I also feel like there's more to explore. This is really cool camp
Uh, where's my stuff over here?
Guys have what's the symbol? These are mesmer soldiers, aren't they? I believe
I take that
Nope. Nope. You're not doing it. You're not doing it. You're not shooting me with no stupid stuff
Uh, what there's another one around here. Okay, that I'm assuming there's nothing here for me
So I will leave this said camp
I wonder what they feed those dogs. Oh my god
The dog is worthless
I need to scratch my ear
Buffs an aoe. Okay
Because then I would just get because like I just
Because again, a lot of this stuff just looks like nightmaid it's miss or like poison miss and stuff. So
Let's come down here
Brassels green and the girl
Or do you have anything in here? No
Come on guys. You guys don't have anything for me to steal over here
Really?
Why are you even here then if I can't steal anything from you?
Run away from the dog run away from the dog run away from this dog
What does it do? I wasn't shooting at me
I don't know. Run away from the dog. What is that?
What is happening over here?
What is that?
What are y'all beating a knight? Okay. Well, I'm gonna run away
Y'all are just beating on each other. What are those are the omen?
Are they horn set? I don't know. Cool. Um
There's a cave. Oh cave
Oh cave
Oh, what's in the cave? Where am I?
Hit the graze
Oh
I feel like I should be having some fire resistant armor
Actually, what was the armor that I picked up?
I picked up something
Not that. Um
That looks crazy. No, it wasn't that it was
Grave bird armor
Oh
I'm just farming rune standing right here. I bet you could literally farm rune sitting here and just like
Although it's 2000 so it's not that much
But still pretty cool
Oh gotta put on my effects hold on
Hold on let me try
By grace have I ever seen of the rock? I shall find it of this I have no doubt
The altar of the forge cannot be for
Whatever the frick that means
Putting the VA and velar baby. I need to probably sit down. I need to take a seat. I'm tired
Bird is better for farm
Bop-bop-bop. I'll probably look really funny. Hold on
What does it do? It's gonna be lightning
I
Drops my poise
Oh
Sorry it's like that noise
I don't really do jump attacks though. You guys haven't seen me do one jump attack
Really isn't better than mogwin interesting. I feel like you might have done that on purpose
Anyways, what's down here? Hello? What the heck?
Oh what
Okay
Uh
Hit them where the week is
What oh and they're booty cheeks
Is this I thought that was a monster um, okay hold on let me get behind you
Yeah, no, this isn't gonna work
Yeah, this isn't gonna work. I'll take this. Thank you. Oh not worth it. It's fine
Oh wow, you're a mimic to you're in a different shade. I love that for you. Um, something in a drip. Yeah
Right there
Smithy why they're
Oh, okay, this isn't this is like the smithing stones place
This is cool very cool
Am I supposed to just jump down or oh I suppose I feel like there's
More to this but you know what?
Oh, this is a trap surely
No, all right
Oh tintate
Potato tate. Um, I'm just gonna not talk to you. That's a cool. Does that oh there's a ladder. Um
That's a cool like golem-y design though
There's this gas stone. Haha. That was me earlier
He he
Are you supposed to like go behind them and like sneakily to be like you know see that even work?
Oh, what's that?
Oh perfect I'll take that
Try to take all these smithing stones
Cool cool cool. Thank you
I
Love the level design really cool dungeon-ish dingy
Oh, you're a big fella, aren't you? This is probably a somber knocks regularly
Oh, I need heal. Oh, what's that?
Okay
So
Get three knives, okay
Yeah, I I am kind of confused why an end game DLC is doing ones and twos but you know, I thought I was just going to be like sombers
Because let's be honest the only thing that people are living up is like Uchigatana
I
Miss anything when I was running through here
Sometimes I have really bad eyesight and I can't tell oh what's over here
Oh, you missed oh, I like how they're just staring at stuff and I was like bye
Sorry gotta go gotta blast
Okay, let's try this again. You could definitely sneak past these guys if you really wanted to oh, it's cool
Is that it?
It seems like it's it. Is there a way to jump up there? There's definitely more to explore here. Ow
I
Definitely I'm gonna climb this ladder
Something's probably gonna shoot me. Can I get on the ladder?
Poco yeah, there's definitely some parkour to be had oh
Um
Uh-huh, I see
Let's try going over there then. Yeah, huh
Poco very it's just very lords of the ring Z ring Z to me
Dude I'm trying to do stuff. Okay, I am getting more smithing stones, which is nice
I
Love like when you place from soft games enough you just realize you don't have to do everything
Like I remember playing where like I was playing only the first time
I thought I had to do like literally everything in the area and like kill everything. I'm like no, I just run past you
Oh
Fascinating
What
Is that gonna go on the lava?
Um, can you not be so close to that?
Oh, I didn't drop uh yikes yikes. Oh
Oh my god
Oh
Big ol pipe be laying some pipe, you know, maybe like that sometimes don't hit me off
Don't hit me off. Thank you. Don't hit me off
You either please don't hit me off
Oh my god
Oh wait
First I'm like is this where I came from is it?
Is this just a loop around
Am I supposed to go higher?
Something tells me I am
Yeah, something you need to keep going up. Okay, let me go do that
Whoa
Can I oh
No, wait, hmm. No, I can't
I
This is fun. I like exploring caves a little cave exploring with you
Yeah
Hey, I forgot the lava doesn't kill you instantly
I thought it was I was gonna like fall in it and I was like it's just a terrible box. Hi
Hello
All right, let's try this again and try not to get
Where did he oh he fell off
Oh, how many runes did he give me when he fell off?
You look
That guy like 34
Oh
No, all right, yeah 34. Oh my god
Nice
These you guys are gonna knock me off or already know
Okay
I
Get out of the way
Oh, okay
Yeah
Wait, I don't want to see what that looks like though
What the heck that doesn't make any sense
Oh
What this though
Anvil hey, okay
Fascinating cool. I'm surprised there wasn't a boss behind that. I'm pretty in the south it only gets down
Oh
Thank you for the compliment. I'm happy you're enjoying watching
Hammer time. What does a hammer do? Is that a is that a weapon?
This is cool. It's a throwing blade interesting. What?
What the heck
Holy crap. Oh, thank you for the five gifts. Hey, mr. Black silence. What a sweetie
It's got a fun ash
I don't think I
Oh
Pretty cool though. Oh, we like sticking out his toesies. Uh, let me change this back
I'm never really like colossal weapons because they move. Oops
Because they move so slow to me
I don't like I like I like being having speed. I am speed
There's a throwing hammer. No, wait, wait, I'm going the wrong way
Oh
Oh, thank you average amphibian for the five gifts. Did you guys are so sweet today with your gifted?
Why you guys being so sweet? Why do we deserve this boomy is touching my
Is this like placing his paws on my arm as he stretches. That's cute. Hi pretty bull
All right, I think I oh wait, there's more
I'm like, I think I'd thoroughly discovered this side. That's incorrect
That is incorrect. So why you guys all fighting? No fighting Shakira Shakira
Those are things from the sewers
I can't really tell
Something chasing me
No, you're just walking slowly towards me
You approach me. Oh, I thought this was entrance to a cave for some reason because of the shadow
Um
Oh, what's that poison nice. Is there anything of use in the poison lake?
Let's skirt the edge
Yeah, you don't have to tell me the viewer count I prefer not to know but thank you
What's over here? Oh, what? Hold on. I'm confused
Okay
Oh you what the heck? Oh, I thought it was something else. It didn't look like it had a tail
Okay, now I see something possibly of value
Isn't that right? I don't know what the heck this is
Co I forget that torrent is fine and poison because torrent's just a bad ad be
Or am I?
I'm literally just doing the most right now what I should be doing
Oh
Oh, oh what there's rats here
There's golden eyes on there. Oh, that's the bonus
Uh, I'm gonna skirt around this don't mind me. I'm not you know
I'm just going by
Oh, thank you doggy. Thank you for the time gifted
Spreading the love giving the giving people discounts for future membership streams that they decided to upgrade
uh
If you've been gifted a membership, um, you get access to all my emotes and I'm getting more on the way
That's why you have these little heart slots there because I'm getting more emotes
Um, but I really do really fun member streams. I just baked a cake. Um the last member stream really fun
That was cool. This person's sitting in the
I don't quite understand why you're there. Why are you sitting in this?
That's okay
More people are getting mentorships. Uh, I don't know. I haven't looked I usually try not to worry about numbers and stuff
Uh, I I don't want to like stress myself out if I'm like, oh, I didn't like get this amount or people blah, blah, blah
But I feel like people definitely enjoy my members content. I like to do watch alongs
Um, I want to do more handcams
um
I do have a watch along I'm gonna do a
I am doing watch along the silly like megan movie with a doll thing and I'm gonna have a heart rate monitor. Um
Because like horror movies, um
But I want to do a hand some hand cam stuff
Yeah, try to make it fun
Have some unique asmr's
Yeah
Wait, can I not talk is this just a rock? What is this?
What is happening here?
Is this glowing rock that why did they put I thought this was a person sitting down
I got a rock
Is that a boulder?
What is this?
What is that?
What am I supposed to do with this?
Can I hit it
Can I destroy this? Oh
Okay
You know what's weird
I feel like they shouldn't
Show the wind because I thought it was working fine. Again. I didn't try to jump in it though
So maybe if you try to jump in it, you wouldn't nothing would happen. That's
Okay, I like how it's like somewhere. Oh, you can clearly see where
Oh, oh here it is
Tailsman of the dread that looks like a badass tailsman
Uh, I want to see what it does
Do you believe I don't use magma?
Oh pale tyrant drake do your wounds yet ache
Is your fury still yet to crest at sena?
Very hurry and lay it all to waste
Lay waste to the proud that conceded each every last one of the arrogant lot
I'm assuming that's where bail is
You're mine. Haha. I got you
Nipi oh, I almost fell off. Uh, let's not do that
All these burned down
places
worn out faces burned down places
That definitely leads somewhere. I think that leads to the
Probably the woods where you fight that sunflower monster kind of looks like that I've seen
Sorry sheep
Talisman tailsman talismans tal is taliyah
Wow gets you pretty far there
Ain't that pretty neat. Don't you know very cool
Okay, let's see here
I see I probably need to unseal that because it looks weird
Do I it's like purple is there pile of rocks in it? No
Yo
What the heck
Skull do where am I?
Uh, well, I'm gonna land right here
Okay
Yeah mortis what I'm here
I could have just probably uh
See is there any maps nearby? No, okay. Oh, I'll figure out how to get there eventually
Stock the landing. Can I please torrent jeez?
Uh frick, how did I get over there?
Oh, yeah, wait, I'll I'll retrace my steps
It's fine we're exploring
It's like you see this you'll see a little fire puppy
Little puppy hound little fire puppy head hand. I boop. I boop just snoot
Wait a second
It was this way
Oh
Oh my god, I took a turn down here
I'm here. Don't fear name chucks out
Collab with kaisen that for ellen ring. Uh, yeah hit him up for me, bro
Just kidding. No men disgusting
Huck toa. No, thank you
In my christian stream. No way. I'm all one of the cloth. I don't do that sort of thing
Only only harlots stream with men, you know, I almost ran off the cliff. It's fine
Yeah
What material source is it gonna have me inquire I'm not really paying attention
True maiden fat and pure see like see I'm made in list, but I am the maiden so
Hmm
I was tempted to like for the watch along to do the a24 movie. That's literally just called men, but I'm didn't
I don't I didn't know if what I was gonna be like
All right, we're back to business we're back we're back, baby
Yeah, oh my god, I must miss that. Why do I feel like it's like more delayed? Where am I? Okay
Let's go
Give me those
Okay, I'm gonna I don't know where to land. I'm gonna aim over here
Because it seems like there's a spot. Yeah, there we go
Because like what the heck was that
Where am I
It's not a map in sight
Oh
Hey, how's it going pretty cool place you got here, uh, I'm just gonna go this way
Don't mind me
Oh, I can't climb up. Don't worry about it. I was trying to look back as I did it and it just didn't like that
You're a very cool looking dude. Oh, you have that
Horn axe thingy
Well, what's going on up here?
Huh, so I'm gonna fall from the sky. I don't trust nothing in this game
What's with this hit it? Yeah, whatever
This is gonna teleport me somewhere
No, wow, I got a psalm. No, I got smithing stone times four
All right
Yeah
Uh, you're probably really strong aren't you? Let me just
Give you a little poke. Oh, you're fine. I got you. Oh, you hit hard and you spit lava. That's fine
Yeah, buddy
Yeah, buddy rolling with the big shots
Secret way to get past castle and citizen rinola, I don't know about it. Congrats for finding it. Oh aren't dice aren't I nifty
I'm the nifty deus nifty that ever nifty'd
What this broken room?
What's down here? I feel like oh, let's go up here because I feel like I'm gonna work my way down
La la la
Oh, why are you? What are you doing do gem? I don't know what that is sounds cool though
I feel like there's a side of grace somewhere
Oh
No, I'm good. Um
I'll chat with you another time
I'm
We're just doing some exploring. Oh, yeah, there's a grace right here. Ta-da
What do I hear in the distance that sounds like it's something that's gonna come in and land
Found a mini boss
All right, oh it's him that's making noise. Uh, I'll go fight them in a second
Let me go fight this dude that I found the grace. I'm surprised
This boss must not be forgiving if there are two graces so close to each other like this that are not really bad
Oh, yeah, you're crucible
You're a crucible dude, aren't you you're a little you're a little crucible boy
Oh, you can come outside. I don't like that. Uh, I'm gonna leave. I love your twin blades though. That's real cool
Real cool. Uh, really like your twin blades
Like your breastplate you're really nice breastplate
Oh, I'm glad you've been enjoying it
I like it's uh spending time with you too. Very good way for me to also decompress just nice, you know
Oh, they were nice enough to put the runes too far away. All right, let's see. What if I
Oh, okay, that doesn't do anything
What if I can I lock him out there so he stays there while I wait for him to do that
Oh, nope. Come outside
Nope
Can I oh you're gonna kill me. No, okay
Okay, no you're not gonna kill me
Oh, you're gonna kill me
I can kind of break
I feel like I should be able to break his poise. Uh, I've only found
I've only found one scatter tree
Fragment
Uh, well, I have like I have one other one, but I need two to go to the next one, you know
All right, let's uh, what else can I do?
Oh, is rock sling effective for you?
Whoa
I
Was hoping I could trap you in this corner doesn't seem like it'll be the case
I can kill you
I feel like you either give me your blades or you give me your armor set and I kind of want either one
So let's do it
Go go flying rock the comet was more effective
I like how he's just like hanging out. He's like, yeah, I can't really jump that
So I guess you're cool to like try to fight that dude
It'd be funny if I could get him to aggro this guy. That'd be funny. Um, maybe I can
Pop off a couple of glint blades. Maybe
Oh, we'll see
I
Didn't really do anything
Whoa, what the heck is happening to my camera?
Oh, fuck. Oh, can you chill out for a second? Kind of let me breathe. Can I breathe? Can I breathe? No
All right, we're not gonna do that
Why did you spoil that I get his Crucible Wings is national war
You
Don't tell me because now I don't care about beating him
Well, maybe I do
The blessings location, uh
No
I prefer I want to
DLC, uh, I'm not going to do what I did with the trying to get through the base game
Don't knock me off. Um
I literally just want to oh common soldier
Uh, I just want to explore and have fun. That's why I said I might not make this
Like a
I only play this and when I stream series because I don't know if
Is there not a ladder here? I don't
Is it a lift?
Is there a hole? It looks like there's a hole if I
Yeah, nice try
Um
Why is this looks like a boss arena when I know it's not?
That doesn't make any sense. Um, I'm gonna creep around him. Let's see what else we got over here
Because I think I think that's just fun, you know
Oh, there's something interesting in front of them though. Oh, you didn't see me
You didn't see me. You didn't see me. You didn't see nothing. You didn't see nothing. Am I here?
Sneak increased
Okay, fine. Well
It's great because I like it tricks their dodge
Oh
Come on give me that blood. Oh, you're gonna kill me
Looks like he just cracked his neck before he did that. That was kind of cool
What
Or you
He should have died he should have died he should I got a little bit greedy
But he should have died
Come on. I know it. You know it. We all know it. He should have died
It's hard to break his poise though
All right
Would you drop he said nah, I win. What are these blessed bones charts?
May I break this
Disrespect your surroundings
No, is there anything in there? I don't know
Oh, I'm assuming this is where you come from
I don't know why the flames scared me for a second. Uh, the crackling was just unnerving. Uh, where am I?
I don't know where I am. I almost fell off the cliff
But I'm gonna go back in there and explore some more
Bring you back to Bloodborne. Uh, I'm not
Okay randomly aggro dragon what's happening over there
Now I'm tempted to go look to see what the heck this dragon is fighting
You
What the hell is that?
Is the sentinel gonna fight it
Because I'm just gonna sit and just like third party this crap this guy can't it's trying to run away and he can't
That's too sad. He's just stuck. That's a shame that guy is trying to shoot it
Oh
Very cool looking dragon, I will say yeah, what the heck? Oh, I'm just gonna sit here and watch
Oh my god, that one has a hammer. That's terrifying
Would not want to mess with that guy
I'm surprised that these soldiers not really doing any damage. Whoa. I like how it attacks and landed in the air
Like that like that that dragon is not affected one bit
I will gladly take all these ruins from you killing everybody though. It's very fun to watch
I'm gonna start commentating this. Oh, I'm getting too close
Uh, I am retreating for safety
Uh, the ghost flame dragon is wrecking these boys. Uh, they've only done a hundred damage
They're bringing up the rear. They're really ganging up on him though because it looks like
Some of them did lay down
Some sort of a aoe not quite sure if there's a
Perfume or among them, but I see some sparkles. Uh, I'm going to run away
I'm running away
Uh, I'm not a part of this
I'm just a commentator. Uh, I'm live on the street
Watching this dragon
Not aggroing it
He has really cool feathery stuff
Oh god, no, I'm not a part of this. I'm leaving
Go fight them not me
Perfect. Okay, we're going back on to the field boys
The dragon has not noticed me
Everybody's kind of dangerously close. They've still only done like a hundred damage
Very cool
I'm live in the action
This horse guy with the hammer you'd think would be doing a lot more damage, but it doesn't seem to be the case
Oh slams down on them
I
Doesn't just eat those arrows. Oh his
Undead drugguses in my face
I really don't like that. I can see through that. That's uncomfortable
Yeah, it's a zombie dragon. I wonder why that is it's just called ghost flame dragon
Oh, I got knocked
Nice stagger keep going for it. Don't come over here
I could probably kill this dragon. I could help him out. Maybe
Do a little cheeky heal
Do a little
Do a little cheeky like, you know, like a little cheeky
A little cheeky comet
A little cheeky glimstone
Oh
Assistance. Oh, I didn't mean to hurt them. That's fine. Um
Oh, I'm out of fp. This is awkward
I can't really tell what damage I'm doing to it to be honest with you
Staggered impressive we're teaming him
We are so good bros. I really honestly should probably get closer
I don't know. One of them is doing some incredible boys damage
What I don't know why that just happened. I am out of fp again
I want to assist but I also don't want them to aggro me
Hey, come over here. I definitely can't reach this far. I don't know why I'm bothering
Oh
There we go. Perfect. Thank you. Yeah. Oh knocked his ass
Oh, he flew away. Nope. Not if I have anything to say about it
No, no, no, no, no, I'm good. I'm busy this day
I'm busy. I'm busy. I got places to be
I'm not a part of this. Dang it
I was just a bystander. I shouldn't have gotten involved. That's what I get, you know
That's what I get for trying to insert myself into the drama
Karma
Oh
Where am I?
Oh, that's right. I heard it from this angle. Uh, what the
Grab my stuff
And I'm gonna go back into the castle. I'll come to back to this later. Nice seeing y'all. Really good day. What the heck? Really good time
Oh
Is there any way to get up there by the way is just
Okay, so it seems like you literally oh
Pardon. Oh, you literally go over here. You just drop down
Oh
That's not what I meant to drink. It's fine
What this cool
Uh
This is where they drop the bodies. Oh, this is where they drop the bodies indeed
Uh, I'm waiting for somebody to jump out of this thing
What is that? What is that? I don't even know what's next to me. Oh, it's him
What is that? What is that? I want it. I can kill you like really easy
Yeah, it's also midnight for me, but I can never sleep
Status death
No way. All right, let me
Go go gadget run away
Oh
Please don't hit me with your fire breath or something. All right. Uh, my stuff's right there. That's fine. Where did he come from?
Oh, there he is
What is the iris of oculation what
Oh
What does that do what does it help me with to quest item
Have you been looking for that eye and you haven't been able to find it what
What is this marica's room?
What's happening? It's too much money. I can't handle that much but not resin
Oh, man, my favorite kind of resin
What does that even do?
Hello
Something gonna fall and attack me
Okay, so this is where you could have also landed
Oh mesmer shoulder ass is interesting. I do I do I am I am a fan of the skeletal militia
Summer say not
Naughty naughty. Oh, are you teasing me?
Hi, I'm back
I should probably heal
Any enemies
No
No, sorry. I sometimes I like ought to lock on because again, I have terrible eyesight and I feel like I can't see people
Are the corner
Where the
Is this this the ramp art? What is that? I was at a boss. Oh wait. No, that's just him
Okay, this
Because then I can literally just jump down over here
Yeah, that's why this is crumbled wall and then uh, he drops the ashes or anything else in there
But he's not gonna come out until I like go really in there. Um, I don't see anything else of interest
There's also dudes inside the castle like if I go down this way
Okay
Have a good night. Good night
Hello, hey, what's cracking brand new whip just cracking
I'm so sorry. I just killed you both feel kind of bad. Uh, it was really awkward
All these dudes are just
No, that's too bad. Oh, that's too bad indeed. Uh, here
Also too bad. I'm so sorry for what happened
Festive grease whoop whoo
Oh no, who that's supposed to kill
Oh
Chair there's a lot of a lot of stuff
Something's gonna jump out
What do I hear?
What do I hear? I hear something
I don't trust it. I don't like what are all these torturey devices
Hey, this looks like my
Looks like wonderland. So heck they they still in decor in here. You got like some stretching tables
Cool axe got like a bear trap for whatever reason. Don't know where I'm supposed to do that
Check your always check your corners boys. That's what I learned. Always check your corners
What the heck where is everyone I feel like this should be like 20 dudes over here
Pickled live up
Probably good to have again. I barely you know, I'm also not a good elden ring the player because I don't use items a lot
I also don't like pay attention to like stacking and like
Like physics stuff or like
Other effects that like um
Who's running at me that uh, some things may have wait what why am I here?
All right, I'm out of here
Almost everybody doesn't oh, I thought it was like a thing that you're supposed to do
Like well, obviously you should it's recommended that you do it. What?
There's a chest. How do I get up there? I need I need uppies
Oh
I hear something
Something right below
Ain't there what there's something up there
Okay, there's a chest there
Why is there nothing attacking me
Where I'm literally locking on a bunch
Because I'm ready to be why are you standing on that like a weirdo?
Come on then
How did that even hurt me? I I didn't understand this because he was a lot of fp. Um
Never got I can charge it. Hey stab. Oh, there's another one. Oh, oh, I see I see what's happening here
ah
nice
Getting my guard down indeed. Just like creepily standing there on top of the thing
Did not expect to get you know
Five guys burger and fries like that to be honest, you know, it'd be easier if I just went inside
Clever girl
It was a decoy
Can you leave messages in this because I'm surprised nobody like left a message like be careful 50 dudes ahead
Actually, uh
I'm trying to think of the fastest way to get there
I can't pass these dudes. Pardon. No, no, this is not what I'm sparing your lives essentially
um
cool
Later nerds are you gonna come down the stairs? Oh my god, you can
You want to come down here too? Oh, yeah, cool. Oh, I missed. It's fine. You punched me. I can't see
Oh my god, why is there so many it's raining man
Hallelujah, it's raining man
Oh, I'll be right with you. Let me come over here
Uh-huh
Oh, I miss I'm not locking on don't kill me. Don't kill me again, please
It's on you stab you all right
I know sometimes like I like picks up my last thing spirit gravestone. I don't know what the hell that be
Any one of you partners want to come out here and farm me like a man instead of throwing pots at me like a wuss
And I'm like, can I get you into one go? Yeah, I can oh what's how are you not dead the heck
I expected I didn't do that. I'm gonna do that, but needless to pretend I did. Um
expected collat
Oh
Watch this be like
nothing
What is a sick like what is that?
What is that?
All right, whatever. Um
I'm very good at access you'll soon discover
So how do I get to that one?
Do I need to
How do I get over there
I did not I don't see
An entrance to said room. Okay, there's stairs leading up but from where
All right
Maybe it's no because that leads upstairs to him. Is there another way over here? Oh, okay. I see no
I didn't know I could go over this way. There's a lot of freaking cages. Jeez
Is anybody over this side? No, all right
Hey, boomie
Something better in this chest
Actually, that's very helpful
I don't really need that
Take that because there's a lot of fire damage stuff
All right, you do your wrong area
All right, let me get out of this
I just teleport. Okay. Yep
Be
Our cages there's so many of you. That's a little cat castle canonically
Is our country home. Oh, boomie. What are you doing? Are you good, bro?
Here's your boy
Squish-squish-squish-squish-squish. Oh pata valley pata valley, boomie
Squish-squish-squish-squish the pouch
Knot what about knots
Tying some knots
I'm actually really tired because it's almost 1 a.m
So I'm gonna end it here
Oh my gosh, I'm falling asleep. I'm really almost just like face-planted under my keyword. Um
Boomie tweaking out. No, he's fine. He's he's even he's tired
He's been a little skittish anxious boy lately. I think that bag really traumatized him. So I think he's
He's really anxious free when I'm
With him. So oh big yawn. Good job, mister
Well, good night. I'll see you guys tomorrow for the big collab
I can't wait lots of cool people are gonna be in it
Uh, feel free to ask a question. That's fine. Um, just so you guys know I'm gonna apologize
Is it gonna be like there's like 15 of us? So chat interactions probably gonna be low. I'll try my best
Um to interact with you guys. Normally, I usually will text message you guys in the chat. Um
Because it's like a pain to like try to mute stuff
Um, yeah
Uh, why is it plans?
What's today
Wait, no today's thursday. Sorry that's
That's saturday. I thought today was friday because but then you said blue site and I'm like wait
I would have been doing streaming at that time
um, because it's
That's tomorrow
Um
Smasher passes a maybe I have to see if Toma's still up for it
Because she's been dealing with some stuff
So we'll see
Uh, wait, it's friday. Wait, what's today?
What day is it? It's friday a second. Okay. Um
I'm use your time. It's friday. So technically today
Because it's 1 a.m. Just about almost for me. Why do I feel like this dragon? I'm gonna turn around. It's gonna be like over on my side
um
Yeah, I started streaming on thursday and I streamed into friday. Oh
Umi keeps tapping me like hurry it up. Um, so technically it's today. Um, we'll be the first one
Uh, it'll be a
What's i'ma call it?
Asmr
Where did I put? Oh, yeah, it's asmr. Um stream and I'm I'm kind of
Going back and I'm doing the asmr with the maid of asche bevelie
And um, but like with added twists and stuff. Um
Um
Second longest viewer stream. What are you talking about? I streamed for like 11 hours once
Um, but yeah, so we'll see
Um, it might be a little bit tame because I'm shy
Um, but we'll see I expect it to be wild as I say I'm gonna be shy. Um
But yeah, we'll see we'll see we'll see. Um
Um
It'll be nice to not have to worry about stuff
So I went to 12 hours. Well, yeah, I don't go to 12 hours. I think I almost I almost said 12 hours
I was like 11 50 because uh youtube stopped like can't the vods get ruined when you go past 12 hours
Um, they won't I literally can't do it. So you have to like end the stream and start another one if you're doing a 24 hour stream
um
But yeah, it'll be cool. And then another week. I want to do another game. I want to play a game. So we'll see
Is there it over 13? Yeah, she did like 15
Oh, no, she did 16 hour legal legends stream. I remember
Little sis dropped me off here. She went right home
Yeah, she'll just look I don't know if she knows what to drive bro. You might have to walk home
um
Yeah
Yeah, that's like this like Elden ring is my comfort game the way that league is like her comfort game
And then I'm pretty I don't I don't know if
Fighting of Isaac is strong. He's comfort game. And I don't know about the other girls. I'll have to ask that'd be a good thing to ask
um
Yeah, she's been like really into runescape and it's really fun fun to see her and then you guys helping her and stuff is sweet
Like the reflings and everybody else and stuff
Every guy I know she was like geeking out over the lord of the rings. I remember she uh when I called her
um
She was telling me about it. She's like I thought I was so polished and then my game froze and I was just like
Kind of eldering our record wants to hunt her cool
Oh
The Elden ring just crashed
It just shut off for me. Okay, that was weird. I don't know why I did that
Yeah, the audio just went but for me like the whole thing closed. I'm just gonna exit and save
No, it's not I want it
Ah, okay, let me do this my remote doing it by my keyboard
Madame she be
She just Elden ring. Yeah. Yeah, we pretty much do
because I was really talking to her about
That I do because she was just like I cheat sometimes I like to look ahead and I'm like I do the same thing
She's like no way and I'm like, yeah, and she's like, yeah, I looked at some like stray stuff
And I'm like, oh my god. I always look at like Elden ring stuff
Um
And then I was just like she'll geek out about lord of the ring and I also like lord of the rings a lot. Um
Yeah, I know right
Yeah, honestly strani is literally me and I'm a little like oh, I forget we were talking about something and
I was
I was like, yeah, and I did this. She's like, no, I do that. I'm like, no, I do that
and we like a lot of the same things like uh, like a lot of the same like music artists
And um, we have a lot of the same humor. So she's literally just me
Except Scottish and I'm literally her except American
Oh
Seller blade, I would just be have the model facing away from me the entire time
Yeah
I know I was thinking about rewatching the lord of the rings, um tv series. I just rewatch the
Um movies with my parents
I
Reena
Strani cut cotton bum and she be cuddles
She be cuddles bun
strani
cut cuddles bum
Cloud with you too. Oh, yeah, I know we've been planning one
Uh, we were actually literally planning one
Uh a collab because I was like, um, I'm kind of pissed off. We haven't collabed yet
And she's like honestly same and then we have the game. I'm very excited. I haven't played
It's honestly a travesty. I've never played this game before. Um, she's like, do you get motion stick easy?
And I'm like, yes, and she's like, great
And I'll like don't worry. I'll still play it because I've always wanted to play it
And I feel like with me and her it'll be so funny. I'm not going to tell you the game
I'll wait for our um, because we're still figuring out the times and stuff
and the date um, but yeah
Oh
I'll wait for our schedule and shit. How about here? Let me move myself to oh
I just dropped my controller
And rena's sitting on my keyboard it takes two. No
I'm not gonna leak it. Oh, yeah, me and shrine the same way. We can't keep a secret but
I think I have a little bit more willpower than her
Keeping
We hi
Sorry when I close out of the game it disappears
Yeah, let's see we'll see
You guys can say bye to boomi for relief
I'm trying to move stuff on my desk. Don't get up. Oh look over here
Talk over here, boomi
Boomi
Got the camera
Look over here, boomi everybody see your blue flies
Like in his goofy face
And she be sniffed
I wish I could pull my camera. Oh, can I oh boomi
Can you sniff the camera boomi
You stink even boomi agrees that you stink ain't that right boomi
What are you looking at he's scared of the tupperware. There's a tupperware right here. He's a staring at it
All right, let me uh
And there's rena
Greenish thief
Reina looks so beautiful in the lighting
What are you staring at
I think she's staring at my headphones because she wants to chew on them
You look so demonic. What's up with that right now? Why do you look like this?
Absolutely glowing
Wait now it's why oh this is my keyboard colors are changing right now over here
Reina
Reina over here she's like watching boomi look at her goofy face as well
What
She looks like she's gonna kill somebody
All right, yeah, if he is sleeping so can't like obviously can't I'm not gonna bring her over here for that
She looks like an anime villain. Yeah
She's charging. She's turned to chaos
All right guys, I'm gonna go to bed
I hope you had a good time. Thank you for spending time with me
Uh, I apologize. Sometimes I get a little silly goose
um
But I love fun
Thank you for taking care of me
And keeping me sane. I couldn't and taking care of me and the kitties
Um, let me make sure I didn't miss any donuts
Okay, no, I didn't cool
Uh, yeah, have a good day. I'll see you guys tomorrow
I didn't mean to wink but
Sure
Okay, bye stinky heads
Bye trash
Discuss you disgust me
You think I was gonna say I love you didn't you?
How presumptuous
To think you're even worth it
Shouldn't even bother saying goodbye should I?
Okay, bye
You missed one
Oh, thank you on on thank you. Oh aren't you cheeky you little cheeky guy with your little last one
Oh, someone also actually don't know it when I ended stream last time on my um
Uh
On my member stream, thank you to that person knows they said it was for the kitty funds. Thank you anonymous
All right
I'm skedalin. I'm going to bed
Later nerds
Sorry, I'm enjoying the music